Das war's für heute.
Bis zum nächsten Mal.
So.
Ich muss gerade die Treppe noch hochflitzen.
Und ich muss
Stream-Vorschau noch anmachen.
Gar nicht hochgefahren.
Treppe rushen, genau.
Omega-Lul.
So.
So, exzellent.
Jetkiss.
So.
Gut, was zu trinken brauche ich gleich noch und ich muss mein Handy aufladen.
So, was ist das?
Ein
Ein RZ-Rack-Simulator
Bauen, verkabeln, automatisieren
Montieren Sie Racks, Server und Switches
Moment, das ist quasi
Arbeitssimulation
Als Game
Ja, warum nicht?
Die haben ganz schön bunte Racks, oder?
Warum haben die da überall LED-Beleuchtung?
Und nee, das ist wahrscheinlich Teil vom Game.
Nee, ich mag solche Games nicht.
Ich mag solche Games nicht.
Ich kann, ich verstehe diese ganzen, in Anführungszeichen, Simulator-Spiele nicht.
So Shop-Simulator, Tavernen-Simulator, Burger-Bugs, backt man Burger überhaupt?
Burger-Brat-Simulator.
Ja, manch, das meine ich nicht.
Farmen-Simulator, da ist ja wirklich was dabei, ja.
Das ist ja wirklich umfangreich und groß.
Ja, aber ich habe auch nichts gegen irgendwelche Flugsimulatoren oder LKW-Fahren oder so.
Aber so diese Mini-Simulationsdinger, ja, du hast irgendwie einen Shop und musst Gras verkaufen oder so.
Gab es ja diese Weed-Simulator und sowas.
So ganz merkwürdig.
Verstehe ich nicht, warum das überhaupt so viele Leute spielen.
Muss es ja irgendwie sein, weil die sprießen ja aus dem Boden wie sonst was.
Und wahrscheinlich liegt das an den ganzen Let's-Play-Leuten, weil man das irgendwie gut als Let's-Play gucken kann oder so.
Ich weiß nicht.
Ich guck mir das immer nicht an.
So, Chat, heute
müssen wir Arch, by the way,
auf eine von den SSDs...
Nee, Leute, ich bin mir immer noch viel besser.
Ich baue mir einfach eine SSD noch ein,
worauf ich Arch installiere, aufs Nass.
Weil ich muss gucken, erstens,
ob die Netzwerk-Performance besser wird
mit Kernel... Was ist der aktuelle?
RC-Kernel 7.1? RC5?
Oder sowas.
Und ob mit dem neueren ZFS
die Probleme mit meinen SSDs erledigt sind.
Das muss ich checken, Kleim.
Haben wir nur zweieinhalb Stunden
Zeit oder sowas in dem Dreh.
So, wo wir gerade dabei sind.
Ich muss ja meine Linux-Kiste anmachen.
Ja, ja. Kann man das irgendwie
ausschalten, dass das immer meckert?
Von wegen, oh, wurde nicht richtig beendet.
Bla.
So.
Jetzt schalten wir mal den Mini-PC ein.
Also, das war jetzt aber langsam.
Ich habe bestimmt schon vor 10 Sekunden den USB-Stecker rausgezogen.
Und jetzt hat es erst diesen komischen USB-Sound gemacht.
Was meinte der?
Stand da gerade der PC meint, es ist 15.26 Uhr?
Habe ich das richtig gesehen?
Naja, knapp vorbei.
Ganz knapp.
So, jetzt hier wieder USB dran.
Exzellent.
CacheOS.
Jetzt muss ich gleich mal gucken.
CacheOS hat doch so eine Kernel-Auswahl-Geschichte.
Kann man da den neuesten RC-Kernel, kann man den da installieren?
CacheOS Kernel Manager gibt es ja bei Manjaro auch.
Kann man da?
Hier, 7.0 RC5, nicht 7.1.
7.0 RC5.
Ja, dann würde ich sagen, installieren wir einfach CacheOS auf dem NAS zum Ausprobieren, ob es der neue Kernel mehr bringt.
Und da ist dann ja auch neues ZFS und der ganze Shit dabei.
Und wenn das dann den einsteht, egal ob es funktioniert oder nicht funktioniert, dann installiere ich noch TrueNAS.
Trunas drauf, um mir das
auch mal anzugucken.
Weil es haben ja viele im Chat geschrieben, Max, was hältst du von Trunas?
Ich muss immer sagen, ja, das letzte Mal, wo ich es
ausprobiert habe, hat mich nicht so überzeugt.
Aber seitdem hat sich ja auch viel geändert.
Aber beispielsweise
ist das Ganze nicht mal Kubernetes basiert.
Ne, das ist nur zum Ausprobieren.
Ich werde das wahrscheinlich nicht
betreiben dann am Ende mit
Arsch und RC-Körnel. Aber selbst wenn,
ganz ehrlich, wenn es ein RC-Körnel ist,
der alle Probleme fixt, warum nicht?
35er Streamserie.
Pog.
Übrigens, Chat.
Hier.
Nitta.
Ich weiß nicht, warum,
aber warum hat dieser Post hier von mir
Warum hat der 507 Likes auf einmal random bekommen auf Twitter?
Das ist...
Vielleicht, weil das so relatable ist
und das jedem schon mal passiert ist oder so.
Keine Ahnung.
Ich verstehe es nicht so ganz.
55.000 Aufrufe, 507 Likes?
Warum?
Ich beschwere mich da jetzt nicht drüber.
Schadenfreude, vielleicht, ja.
Ja, das ist auch wieder geil.
Alter, wie viel Wichtigtuer hier wieder am Start waren.
Kein Backup, kein Mitleid, lul.
Wenn ich so das Gelaber immer höre.
Max, hast du die Katze wieder entkürt?
Die Katze, die war heute Morgen da und hat sich ausführlich streichen lassen und natürlich auch füttern.
So, jetzt müssen wir erstmal hier Updates machen.
Warum? Weil ich es nicht haben kann, wenn mein System älter als eine Viertelstunde ist.
Guck hier, bam. Direkt Updates.
GIP-Pakete auch.
Chatterino wird geupdatet.
GIP 7.
Oh, Toolbox-Update.
Alles geupdatet hier.
Bam, guck mal da.
Update all.
Richtig große Update-Orgie am Laufen.
Guck mal, so viele Updates am Laufen, dass der eine Updater gar nicht mehr updaten kann, weil der andere Updater gerade updatet.
So muss das sein.
Ja, alles was älter als eine Viertelstunde ist, ist mir nicht Bleeding Edge genug.
Oh, hier muss man das Passwort eingeben.
Zack, zack.
War ein Kernel-Update eigentlich dabei?
War ein Kernel-Update?
Nee, kein Kernel-Update, oder?
Ja, dann müssen wir auch nicht rebooten, wenn kein Kernel-Update.
Doch, hab ich.
Aber die Katz wohnt ja nicht bei mir.
Die wohnt ja daheim.
Ansonsten verstehe ich den Zusammenhang jetzt nicht.
Die kommt einmal am Tag vorbei, lässt sich ein bisschen streicheln und füttern.
Die Leute können mich ja verklagen, wenn ihnen das nicht gefällt.
Ich glaube nicht, dass das verboten ist.
Ich habe auch die Kommentare gelesen, dass ich angeblich Mikrorisse im Mainboard habe.
Falls sich noch einer daran erinnert.
Bis jetzt habe ich noch keine Probleme durch die Mikrorisse, Leute.
Obwohl ja laut Chat und Kommentaren das komplette Mainboard voller Mikrorisse sein soll, angeblich.
Ich weiß auch gar nicht mehr warum.
Ich glaube, weil ich das Mainboard auf der Seite liegen hatte oder irgendwie sowas.
Keine Ahnung, was damals mit den Leuten los war.
Zumindest wurde mir prophezeit, ich habe jetzt ganz viele Mikrorisse im Mainboard.
Kommentar zum Fremdschämen, oh ja, da gibt es jede Menge.
Jeder zweite Kommentar, den ich lese, ist zum Fremdschämen
Nicht hier im Chat, oder auch nicht unbedingt bei mir auf Twitter
So generell ist gefühlt jeder zweite Kommentar zum Fremdschämen
Es gibt ja nichts, habe ich den Eindruck, was die Leute mehr triggert
Wenn jemand anderes was gepostet hat, was aus ihrer Sicht nicht stimmt
Da wird auch nachts um halb drei aufgestanden, um schnell den Rechner einzuschalten und auf Reddit zu posten
nee, du hast nicht recht.
Und der Witz ist dabei,
die Leute, die das oftmals so ganz besonders überzeugt
schreiben, die haben selbst keine Ahnung.
Wobei ich bin ja, das muss ich mal sagen, ich bin ja auch
teilweise pingelig, ne, wenn wir irgendwelche Videos
gucken und ich da irgendwie
sage, ah, das könnte man jetzt, das Wort könnte man jetzt
anders benutzen oder ah, nee, das könnte man anders
interpretieren, dann kann ich da auch eine Viertelstunde
drüber rumphilosophieren,
weil ich total bescheuert ist, weil in der Regel hat er das
wahrscheinlich korrekt gemeint.
So, Update Orgy ist durch.
Dann gehen wir doch mal hier auf unsere
AVM.
Die
nicht geht.
Ey, guck mal.
Firefox, die haben
eine neue Gehtnicht-Seite, oder?
Die ist neu, oder, Chat?
Das ist auch das neue Firefox-Maskottchen.
Ich habe vergessen, wie er heißt.
Den haben die Ende letzten Jahres vorgestellt.
Der neue Firefox-Maskott.
Neues Firefox.
New.
Kit heißt er, genau.
Kit.
Das ist er.
Hast du mal LibreWolf getestet?
Ne.
Wobei Kid sieht da ein bisschen anders aus
als da.
Aber man erkennt es schon. Das soll es schon sein.
War Kid nicht das Auto
aus Knight Rider?
Um mal irgendwelche uralten Sachen
aus meiner Kindheit aufzugreifen.
Kannst du empfehlen?
Okay, warum?
Ähm, warte mal
Warum LibreWolf
Versus Firefox
Also was ist der
Große Vorteil
Firefox ohne Mozilla Pay
Okay und was ist der Größte
Was ist aus eurer Sicht
Firefox verkauft Daten
Aber die sagen doch immer sie sind so richtig krass
Privacy Pro und so
Stimmt es etwa nicht, wenn die das sagen?
Wollt ihr sagen, die erzählen was, was nicht stimmt?
Das kann ich mir aber nicht vorstellen.
Wer würde denn sowas machen?
Wann haben uns irgendwelche Unternehmen schon mal Sachen erzählt, die nicht stimmen?
Kann ich mich nicht dran erinnern, dass das jemals vorgekommen ist.
Die könnten bei Mozilla auch einfach mal das machen, was nice ist und nicht tausend andere Sachen.
So nach dem Motto, Firefox wird ein AI-Browser.
Alle, Alter, geht uns nicht auf den Sack.
Ja, dann hatten sie irgendwie, was weiß ich, fünf verschiedene Link, Shortlink, Linksharing, Bookmark, Services und hast du nicht gesehen.
Was tatsächlich, Pocket, Pocket war tatsächlich ganz nice, wurde jetzt mittlerweile wieder eingestellt.
Ja, für was auch immer der das bekommt.
Ich meine, ich bin ja normalerweise gar nicht so sehr dafür, Vorstände und Chefs zu flamen.
Weil es gibt halt einfach wenige, die diesen Job machen wollen.
Und ich glaube, ganz viele Leute, von denen die immer drüber meckern, so nach dem Motto, Alter, die kriegen so unnötig viel Geld.
Die würden das im Leben nicht machen wollen oder machen oder auf die Reihe bekommen.
Und, was immer vergessen wird, wenn es heißt, der Chef von Unternehmen XY bekommt so und so viel Geld, das ist ja Gehalt.
Der ist ja auch nur Angestellter, der eingestellt wurde und eigentlich sollte man dann eher stinkig sein auf die, die dem diesen Vertrag gegeben haben.
Airpods US, stimmt, das war ja auch mal ein Ding.
Stimmt ja
Firefox OS
Aber Firefox OS selbst ist nicht mehr
Gibt es nicht mehr, oder?
Wurde das überhaupt mal irgendwo drauf ausgeliefert?
Chat, ich muss mal kurz
Ich muss mal kurz mein KVM einschalten
Keine Ahnung, warum der auch
Oder die auch
Ist es die, der das KVM
Der Switch, oder?
AVM Switch, der Switch
Bis zum nächsten Mal.
So, ich habe mir gerade noch Tee geholt.
Thunderbird Pro kommt jetzt
sagst du zum Chebaten oder ist es wirklich so
ich trau das denen ja mittlerweile
problemlos zu
es hab ich schon alles wieder verdrängt
ich versteh auch gar nicht
wie man es bei Mozilla
ich hab es schon öfters die letzten Jahre
immer gesagt so verkacken kann
die hatten einen richtig
guten Browser
vor allem den besten Browser eigentlich für Entwickler und technisch interessierte Leute.
War Firefox der beste Browser.
Und die haben es irgendwie komplett verspielt die letzten Jahre.
Ich weiß auch nicht, wie man das auf die Reihe kriegt.
Ich meine, ich bin immer noch froh, dass es Firefox gibt.
Weil zumindest mal eine Alternative zu Chrome ist ja nicht verkehrt.
Ansonsten gibt es, okay, Safari.
Aber Safari ist keine Alternative für irgendwas.
Gibt es eigentlich noch Safari für Windows?
Das gab es ja mal.
Okay, es gibt keine aktuelle offizielle unterstützte Version.
Apple hat den Support für Windows 7 Jahr 2012 eingestellt.
Okay.
Ja.
Der weltschnellste Browser.
Das ist ja auch kein Wunder.
Der kann ja auch nichts.
So, es ist jetzt mittlerweile da hier.
Ja, excellent.
USB-Stells.
Excellent.
Tja.
Da würde ich sagen, dann booten wir jetzt mal da drauf
Ein
Cache-OS oder installieren uns auf irgendeine SD-Cache-OS
Mal gucken, ob die Musik nicht zu laut ist
Oh ne, da ein ganz kleiner Tickenleiser
Können wir machen
So, ja, so ist gut
Warum ruckelt das denn jetzt auf einmal so?
Alter, was macht denn hier so viel CPU-Last?
Was ist das denn?
Guck mal hier, der ganze Rechner ist am Abspacken
Was macht... Alter
Was ist...
WTF?
Das ist die KVM?
Die so viel RAM belegt, oder?
Was ist das?
Jetzt ist gut, Moment, Moment, da müssen wir jetzt mal zugucken
Guckt euch das mal an
Jetzt geht's auf einmal.
Oder auch nicht.
Oh, doch.
Guck mal, guckt euch das mal an.
Das ist voll am eskalieren
Und jetzt hängt der komplette Rechner
Der komplette Rechner hängt jetzt
Guck dir das mal an
Alter
Ich hatte das auf Raw umgestellt
Okay, ist das
Wo hatte ich das umgestellt? Settings?
Ach hier, da, Watch
Okay, WebRTC haben wir jetzt
Mal gucken, ob WebRTC weniger Probleme macht
Chat, seid ihr das etwa?
Seid ihr drin schon?
Lockt euch mal wieder aus von meiner KVM, Chat.
Okay, WebRTC funktioniert deutlich besser, so wie es aussieht.
Ach, RF-Programmer, du bist das.
Oh, ich hatte ja einen Stromausfall.
Mal gucken, ob überhaupt mein PXE-Boot noch funktioniert.
Scheint zu funktionieren.
Gucken wir mal.
Gucken wir mal, ob der noch funktioniert jetzt.
Also, ich könnte ja auch...
New Version Available.
Ich könnte ja auch mal meine KVM updaten.
Von 1.61 auf 1.32.
Optimizations and Fixes.
Aha.
Mehr nicht.
Ne.
Wird nicht geupdatet.
Okay, wir...
Warte mal.
Achso, Moment.
Bevor wir neu starten.
Also ich zeige euch jetzt mal den aktuellen Ist-Stand
Und da seht ihr, dass das nicht so geil ist
Monk HW
Ich bin hier verschluckt am Tee
Also
Guck mal, ich zeige euch mal kurz den
Den Ist-Stand
Also
Es gibt da ein Problem
Wenn ich jetzt hier auf meine SSD gehe, das ist Z-Pool, das ist ein ZFS, ein ZFS, ein Single ZFS Disk.
Normalerweise sind Raid 1, aber ich habe die zweite Platte zu Testzwecken gerade rausgemacht.
Single Pool ZFS.
Und wenn ich da jetzt ein Benchmark drauf starte, so hier zum Beispiel den da,
Dann sieht das erstmal schnell aus, aber nach so 1-2 Minuten geht es runter.
Das ist by the way normal, weil dann irgendwann der Cache von der SSD aufgebraucht ist, ja.
Aber das geht richtig hart runter, das geht runter auf 400-500 MB.
Oder auch nicht.
Chat, jetzt plinke ich nicht mehr durch.
Warum ist das jetzt schnell?
Das letzte Mal war das noch abfucklangsam?
Ist das wieder ein Bug in dem Nass?
dass das, wenn man das einmal komplett
Power-Off, Power-On macht, dass dann
ja, weil
ganz ehrlich, mit der Geschwindigkeit kann ich
jetzt ohne Probleme leben, ne?
Das ist vollkommen fein.
Aber wir gucken mal,
wir warten mal, wir warten mal, bis die
bis der Cache von der
von der SSD voll ist.
Ja, Arch zum
ausprobieren, ob mit der neuen Kernel-Version...
Nee, nee, nee. Stable Debian ist zu alt.
Ich glaube, Stable Debian hat...
Hat Stable Debian 6.15
plus Kernel, dann wird es theoretisch sogar
funktionieren.
Weniger? Na, dann unterstützt es meine...
unterstützt es meine...
Netzwerkkarte nicht.
Warum kein TrueNAS?
TrueNAS probieren wir danach aus.
die nächsten Tage dann.
Okay, Chat,
ich checke es null. Ich checke es
nicht mehr. Warum ist denn jetzt die SSD
auf einmal schnell?
Nachdem ich komplett das Ding
jetzt einen Tag oder so vom Strom hatte.
So, wir gucken mal bei Sensors.
10 Gig,
10 Gig Netzwerk.
Das macht aber auch Probleme.
Also, guck mal.
Die Temperatur, an der liegt es ja auf gar
keinen Fall. Temperatur vollkommen
fein.
Cash, ja
Aber normalerweise war der Cash viel schneller
Wieder voll
Ich mein, guck mal, der hat jetzt ja schon
Keine Ahnung
Was hat der jetzt schon geschrieben
100 Gig oder so
Oh ja, das ist es bestimmt, DCC-RAM
Fuck, Leute, ihr habt recht
Soll ich mal
Ein Freenas-Forum fragen, was das Problem ist
Oder noch besser
Ein Mikrocontroller-Forum
Ich glaube, da kriegen wir bestimmt sehr hilfreiche Antworten
Moment, Moment, Moment
Haben die überhaupt ein Forum für was anderes als
Haben die so ein normales
PC-Forum oder sowas
Level 1 Tech-Forum
Ne, das sind ja gescheite Leute
Ich will doch nur auf
Ah hier, guck mal
PC-Hard und Software
Da fragen wir
das Mikrocontroller-Forum einfach mal.
Jungs, was meint ihr, warum mein ZFS...
Aha, hier. Jetzt ist der
Cache voll, Leute. Jetzt ist der Cache
voll.
Aber das ist immer noch vollkommen
fein.
Die Geschwindigkeit ist vollkommen in Ordnung jetzt, ne?
Jetzt ist der...
Der Cache ist SLC, ne?
Und die normalen Flash-Speicherzellen sind TLC?
Oder wie ist das?
Ich kann das immer nicht merken.
Chat, das Problem mit den SSDs hat sich anscheinend erledigt.
Die SSD ist jetzt schnell.
Random.
Random schnell SSD.
Okay, nice.
Dann gucken wir noch.
Ich glaube, ich habe das letzte Mal ein bisschen dran rumgebastelt.
Und ich glaube, ich habe das letzte Mal Sync ausgeschaltet.
Kann das sein?
Das wollen wir ja eigentlich nicht haben.
Okay, das...
Das enablen wir mal wieder.
Und gucken wir mal, wie schnell es dann ist.
Always.
Standard.
Bestimmt wegen ECC-Ram.
Alter, ihr mit eurem ÖCC-Grab immer.
Okay, gucken wir nochmal.
Das ist immer noch okay.
Das ist immer noch vollkommen fein, Leute.
Vollkommen fein, die Geschwindigkeit.
Und die Temperaturen sind auch in Ordnung.
Guck hier, kannst du dich nicht beschweren.
naja aber ihr habt im letzten stream gesehen das ding war irgendwie auf 650
mb die sekunde oder sowas das ist immer noch das n5 er ja
ok anscheinend anscheinend keine probleme dann
tätschen wir mal die zweite disc wieder und machen den raid 1 raus
Moment mal.
Attach.
Ich muss das richtig machen.
Wartet mal.
Das ist falsch rum.
Das ist falsch rum, ne?
Muss ich so machen?
Ich glaube...
Ich glaube, so rum muss ich machen.
Ich kann mit dieser ZFS-Geschichte immer nicht mehr...
Ja, okay, so rum.
Das ist ein Schreibfehler in der Fehlermeldung.
Echt? Wo denn?
Is in use and contains?
Du meinst, weil es
an unknown filesystem sein muss, oder was?
Chat.
Der Chat ist heute wieder extrem hyperkorrekt, habe ich den Eindruck.
Gleich auf Reddit posten, Leute.
Gleich, nee, noch besser.
Chat.
Direkt, Leute.
Ihr solltet direkt auf GitHub gehen.
Und es posten.
Das App bezieht sich auf File System.
Richtig.
Siehst du?
Chat, High IQ.
So, ZFS Zpool-Status, der re-silvert jetzt noch 1-2 Minuten.
Jetzt lassen wir den mal re-silvern.
Und dann mache ich nochmal das FIO.
Und dann schauen wir mal.
Und dann installiere ich mir auf der zweiten SSD Arch
und gucke, ob mit der neuen Kernel-Version es schneller geworden ist,
was die Netzwerkkarte angeht.
Mein aktuelle Baseline, was Netzwerkkarte angeht, kann ich euch ja nochmal zeigen.
IPERF, BAM, Terminal, IPERF, IPERF.
Also hier, so um die 9 Gig schwankt er in die eine Richtung.
Und 8,85.
So, und in die andere Richtung ist er ein bisschen schneller.
Oder auch nicht.
Äh.
Oh Gott.
Diese Netzwerkkarte macht mich fertig.
Und da.
Also die Netzwerkkarte.
Das kannst du komplett knicken.
Ja so müsste das eigentlich sein.
Schon besser.
Ja also irgendwie um die 9 Gig.
8.
8,5 bis 9 Gig so.
Und.
ich habe jetzt halt ein custom treiber vom hersteller mir wäre es deutlich lieber ich
könnte den in in in köln treiber verwenden und ich krieg vielleicht auch noch ein bisschen mehr
speed in beide richtungen also dass hier einmal mehr als das hier geht nicht das ist das ist
quasi voller voller 10 gb speed aber in die andere richtung könnte ich noch ein bisschen
mehr bekommen so mal gucken aber fertig wie silvan ist mit cds der riesen wird immer noch
noch 27 sekunden 25 sekunden 24 sekunden
also erzähl ich nicht mehr gut und dann kommen wir mal meinen px e boot
funktioniert wir müssen so merken hier chat auf die festplatte oder auf die ssd
auf die einfach mehr ist dass die installieren wir jetzt gleich cash ios
zum Ausprobieren.
Ich muss es auf die richtige machen.
So, es ist fertig.
Resilvert und jetzt Fio.
Immer noch vollkommen okay.
Also ehrlich, bei der
SSD-Geschwindigkeit kann ich mich
jetzt beim besten Willen nicht beschweren.
Temperatur auch vollkommen in Ordnung.
Hier irgendwas um...
Was davon ist jetzt das, worauf es ankommt?
Keine Ahnung.
Ah, der hier wird ein bisschen warm, aber...
Ist noch weit von 65.261,8 Grad entfernt.
Ich glaube, so ab 100 Grad ist schlecht.
Aber das ist auch noch vollkommen
Fein hier
Die kriegen ja auch gerade voll IO drauf
Geballert
Also insofern
Das ist das Feine
Okay Leute, meine SSD Probleme haben sich erledigt
Ich hab legit keine Ahnung
Was der für Schmerzen hatte
der SSD-Speed hier ist vollkommen
top und fein, alles gut,
ja,
dann werden wir da bei der Gelegenheit
doch jetzt gerade nochmal gucken,
wenn er doch
so schnell ist, wie
viel, weil wir hier gerade eh schon Proxmox
am Laufen haben, wie
schnell ist er denn jetzt beim
Pfeil übertragen auf das NAS noch
einmal, sodass wir so eine Baseline-Sache
haben. Nehmen wir mal die
Open Media Vault VM,
Probieren wir es mal mit der aus, wie schnell er da heute ist.
Gehen wir mal drauf.
Ich glaube, das war 2.52.
Grupp.
Perfekt, da sind wir.
So, hier nochmal ein IPR drauf checken.
Auf die 4M.
Bam, volle Pulle
Geht ab
Mit üblichen
Schwankungen, die keiner sich so richtig
erklären kann, aber geht ganz gut
Minus
Ja
Könnte geiler sein
Oder
also so der Wahnsinn ist es nicht.
Könnte besser sein.
Also ich hätte lieber,
ganz ehrlich, ich hätte lieber einen Gig mehr.
9,5 wäre mir lieber als 8,5.
Weil dann
würden wir quasi
10 Gig maxen.
Also mehr geht da nicht.
Aber 8,5 ist ein bisschen wenig.
Okay, dann schauen wir doch jetzt mal,
wie die Übertragung hier ist
übers Netzwerk.
Ist es max?
1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, Gott sei Dank
Okay, mal gucken, ob wir da jetzt was drauf
Kopieren können, ob die
So, wir kopieren
Jetzt, wartet mal, ich brauche
Ein großes File, die Stream4M
Das ist ein großes File
Ups
Okay
Das braucht ein bisschen, das ist
normal dass das 2 3 4 5 10 sekunden braucht bis es sich irgendwie ein
gedingst hat
ok also wir schwanken irgendwie so um
ja 900 ich würde mal sagen so im durchschnitt irgendwas 900 megabyte die
sekunde das geht schon besser so super geil ist das net also ich so ist es
dürfte es dürften schon so 1,1 gigabyte oder 1,2 gigabyte sein
zockt so aktuell irgendwas ja aber nix jetzt nichts großartig bekanntes
kleine kleine Sachen da über Steam. Ich habe letztens wieder einen Playthrough
Orks Must Die 2 gestartet. Das ist immer noch beste Tower Defense. Expedition 33 habe ich
immer noch nicht abgeschlossen. Habe ich irgendwie keinen Bock mehr. Oh guck mal, ist ein bisschen schneller geworden.
Also sagen wir mal 950. 950 MB im Durchschnitt.
Ja, also kann man mit leben.
Kann man mit leben.
Aber wäre schon nice, wenn es ein bisschen mehr gäbe.
Fände ich jetzt.
Dann gucken wir doch nochmal auf unserem...
Auf unserem LXC-NAS.
Ob das jetzt schneller ist.
Stream da doch mal
Ich weiß nicht, ob das so spannend ist
Wenn schon, würde ich aber nur die
Nightmare-Challenges streamen
So, Summary
Äh
Public Share 1
Public Share 2
Ähm
Gute Benahmung, Max
Da weißt du sofort wieder Bescheid, ne?
Was?
There's not enough space.
Ach so, ah, ich hab das nicht gemounted, gell?
Ups.
Ach, ich muss ja auch in die VM hier.
53.
ok jetzt darf ich jetzt
ok irgendwas habe ich da kaputt gemacht ich glaube ich muss nochmals ja ok ich
sehe ja mode noch mal
ich weiß nicht was ich da getrieben habe
Was?
Not accessible? Wie jetzt?
Okay.
So, und auf meine LXC-Kiste...
Äh...
Okay.
Ähm...
Was hat der für Schmerzen?
Okay, das sieht ja richtig gut aus.
Okay, whatever.
Also, irgendwas im 950 MB.
Keine Ahnung, was der wieder verschmerzt hat.
Warum das nicht funktioniert, ist mir auch egal.
Power off, bam.
Gut.
So, Open Media Vault können wir auch power offen.
und dann installieren wir jetzt mal Arch,
by the way.
Reboot.
Da muss ich jetzt
ganz schnell
U-Menü
hämmern.
Die Systemplatte.
Eigentlich sollte ich nicht auf die Systemplatte
geschrieben haben, weil
die nur 32 Gig groß ist, der sonst
gemeckert hätte, dass sie nicht groß genug ist und ich extra
gemountet habe. Kann schon sein.
So, hier.
Ein bisschen laggy die KVM, aber egal.
Also Boot.
Boot-Menü.
Ich will booten
von meiner
Netzwerkkarte.
Will ich booten. Dann hoffen, dass ich
PXE booten kann.
Okay, sieht gut aus.
Was nicht klappt, also ein Problem hat sich heute schon erledigt, aus irgendwelchen Gründen, die SSD-Geschwindigkeit ist heute vollkommen top und fein.
Es gibt aber Patches für die Netzwerkkarte, sodass ich eventuell mit dem Kernel-Treiber auskomme und mich nicht mit dem Hersteller-Treiber rumschlagen muss.
Was jetzt nicht unbedingt heißt, dass ich auf dem Ding Arch Linux installiere und das wirklich dann live betreibe
Aber es ist zumindest gut zu wissen, wenn es mit Kernel 7.0 erledigt ist
Dann kann ich nämlich einfach noch ein paar Tage warten, dann gibt es den neuen LTS Kernel und dann ist gut
Also, wir installieren CacheOS, habe ich gesagt, ne
Irgendein Arch, ist mir vollkommen wurscht, CacheOS hat alles dabei, machen wir so
Äh
Chat
Chat, was
Was hat der für Schmerzen?
Das sieht nicht gut aus, oder?
Warum bootet das von da nicht?
Liegt das an meinem PXE-Server?
Oder an was liegt das?
Das können wir einfach ausprobieren.
Ups.
Wir starten mal hier kurz vor MWR.
Das Device gibt es ja wirklich.
Da wären wir nicht drauf gekommen, dass das Device es gibt.
Network Boot
Vielleicht ist beim Stromausfall auch irgendwas abgekackt auf meinem PXE Server
Übrigens, das BIOS Boot, das ging das letzte Mal
Jetzt geht es aus irgendwelchen Gründen wieder nicht
Das liegt irgendwie an meinem Switch oder an dem DHCP von meinem Router
Keine Ahnung, nicht am Switch, am DHCP vom Router
dass das manchmal nicht funktioniert.
Ich habe keine Ahnung warum. Ich habe den
IP-Adressenraum sogar
schon erweitert. Also sprich, das kann halt auch
nicht daran liegen, dass die
IPs ausgehen oder sowas.
Wenn wir hier mal
auf UEFI um, dann funktioniert es instant.
Routen Network.
Gucken wir mal, ob das hier schon
gebootet hat mittlerweile.
Okay.
Also Cashew ist das irgendwie
Procken
Das könnte aber in der Tat
Wirklich Procken sein, ne
Weil ich lad mir das ja einmal am Wochenende neu runter
Und in der Nacht von Sonntag
Auf
Montag
Lädt er neu runter
Und es könnte sein, dass das aktuelle
Cashew-ISO einen Bug hat
Gucken wir mal
Ob es hier bootet
guckte mal das aktuelle cash iso ist kaputt
haha
das liegt nicht an mir oder beim pixi ist aber das cash iso ist kaputt dann müssen wir uns mal
chat kann man man kann sich doch bestimmt auch wie installiert man sich dann jetzt mal
angenommen man hat einen rockmann hat einen rohr arch wie installiert man sich unter einem
rohr arzt denn jetzt am besten den rc können ohne ihn selbst zu kompilieren geht das
Das haben wir schon mal gemacht.
Ey, das ist was, was cache.us zur Verfügung stellt.
Allerdings, dann downloaden wir jetzt einfach die neueste ISO und schieben das auf die,
auf das KVM.
wir downloaden direkt achter dritter neuestes iso bäume bäum und das geht aber zackig
ich weiß nicht wie man am besten die keck die die cash repos einbindet unter einem normalen
arsch wahrscheinlich ist es kein großes problem wird jetzt einfach mal drauf
tritt man mich nicht gemacht habe ich tippe darauf ist kein großes problem
ja und vor allem wisst ihr die schlips aus ford das ist die schlimmste seite
die ist ungefähr in zehn prozent der fälle ganz normal schnell und ansonsten
landet man auf irgendwelchen reutig und server am arsch der welt
also source ford ist ganz grausam
Ich mach das jetzt nur um zu testen, ob meine Netzwerkkarte damit schneller ist.
Die SSD-Probleme haben sich aus irgendwelchen Gründen wieder erledigt.
Sourceforge wird früher, pre-GitHub, war Sourceforge und wie hieß das andere?
CodeProject.
Kennt das noch jemand?
Gibt's das überhaupt noch?
Ach, Code Project gibt es gar nicht mehr.
Jetzt gibt es ja noch Code Project AI Server.
Check ich net. Was sollte denn das überhaupt sein?
naja
code project war früher auch nice für tutorials und sowas so iso ist runtergeladen wie fanden
das jetzt richtig track or click to upload files ok das alte cash us wobei das alte cash us lasse
ich mal drauf. Wer weiß, nicht, dass die so jetzt
komplett kaputt ist.
Download.
Äh, CacheOS.
Guck dir mal, Leute. Ich lade
schneller aus dem Internet runter,
wie ich auf meine
lokale KVM das ISO hochlade.
Übrigens mega nice, ne?
Dass man das da hochladen kann.
Man hat quasi ein KVM
mit einem integrierten USB-Stick, wenn man
so will. Ziemlich nice, das Ding.
Ich finde das übrigens eh gut.
Also diese GL-KVM.
Also bis jetzt...
Moment, ist das die?
Ne.
Ne, die da.
Die da.
Hast du Pi-KVM?
Pi-KVM mal ausprobiert.
Ne, ich habe auch keine Jet-KVM.
Was kostet der Spaß?
Ja, ist nicht ganz billig.
Aber immer noch, also wenn man sich mal anguckt, was Profi-KVMs kosten, ist es der Witz, ja.
Da kannst du bei manchen Geräten ja fast eine Null hinten dran hängen.
Was haben die da auf ihrer Webseite? Haben die schon wieder was neu?
Remote-KVM über das Internet. Ist das nicht eigentlich das Letzte, was man will?
Ist nicht das Letzte, was ich will, dass meine Server random über das Internet verfügbar sind, dann aber per KVM?
Wo man ins BIOS und überall hinkommt?
Warum muss das über das Internet verfügbar sein?
Das ist wirklich das Letzte, was man haben will, oder?
Ach, guck mal, die haben wieder was Neues.
Ah, nee, das ist ein bisschen abgespeckter anscheinend.
Naja, so.
ISO ist hochgeladen.
Chat sagt ihr ISO oder sagt ihr ISO wie das manche besonders coolen Leute machen
Wie
Wie kann ich dem jetzt sagen, was er mounten soll?
So?
Ja, ne?
Don't remind me.
Okay, reboot.
Also das funktioniert nicht richtig.
Toolbox, Control Alt Delete.
So.
Und jetzt hämmern wir gleich.
Enf und booten.
Kommt.
So.
Und jetzt hämmern wir gleich
Enf
und Booten
vom CD-Laufwerk.
Hier.
Das
bootet eher wie ein USB-Stick, würde ich sagen.
ISO sagst du auch manchmal.
Du sprichst es komplett aus
Ah, okay, natürlich, natürlich
Du sagst jedes Mal internationale Organisation für Normung
Wer nicht? Wer kennt es nicht?
Ja
Okay, zack
Oh, es klopft an meiner Tür
Oh, Chat, es gibt was zu essen
Okay.
Ich hab was zu essen gebracht.
Kriegt.
Pog.
Da hau ich mir jetzt mal kurz ein Stück Abel rein.
Ich gebe Toastbrot.
Ich wusste gar nicht, dass ich dieses E-Mode hinzugefügt habe.
Aber das ist ja passend jetzt.
Naja, kein Ketchup.
Ist Toastbrot. Warte mal.
Toastbrot mit
Salami und Feta-Käs.
Käse.
Vor allem.
Feta-Käs.
Und Appel.
Captain Dormans trinken.
Ja, hast du recht.
Da sind wir.
Launch Installer.
Bam.
Warum kein Proxmox?
Doch, doch, da kommt später schon noch Proxmox drauf.
Ich will nur gucken, ob ich meine
Netzwerk und SS...
Oh, oh, oh.
Nicht runtergeschissen, runtergeschmissen.
Äh.
Ob ich meine SSD
und Netzwerk-Performance-Probleme mit einem
neueren Kernel in den Griff kriege.
Wo zum Teufel ist Englisch?
United Kingdom Englisch.
Chat, wo ist Englisch?
Also wenn Englisch schon mal nicht Englisch heißt, geht mir das schon mal auf den Sack.
Ja.
British English. American English.
Alter.
Okay.
Gibt's auch Schwedisch-English.
Wobei Schwedisch-Arabisch eher.
Ist das nicht so? Haben die nicht ja mittlerweile
ganz viele arabisch sprechende Leute?
So, Berlin.
Next.
Generalic, Default.
Nee, nee, nee, nee. German.
Äh.
dass wir hier booten, keine Ahnung.
Mir eigentlich vollkommen egal.
Ja, nehmen wir das.
Ist eigentlich wurscht.
Erasedisk?
Ne?
Äh.
Hmm.
Ich bin gerade aber überlegen, ich könnte es auch einfach auf diese Festplatte hier installieren.
Dann könnte ich mal die SSD
Gescheit testen
Von
Von CacheOS aus
Ich installiere das auf der lahmen alten Platte
Das ist doch egal
Ich meine, was will ich da großartig rum machen
Das ist okay
Erasedisk
Okay
Jawohl
Mal gucken, wie lahm das auf einer
äh, Magnetplatten-Geschichte-Installation ist.
Man sollte sich eigentlich auch in Grenzen halten, oder?
Ja, passt alles so.
KDE, BAM.
What is your name?
Max.
Omega Lul.
Pog.
Okay, install.
Gib ihm.
Tempel OS
Hat das überhaupt noch weiterentwickelt?
Der ist ja gestorben vor ein paar Jahren
ein Tempel OS Entwickler
Ne
Oder?
Bin nicht mehr weiterentwickelt
Tempolos Website
Downloads
Es gibt keine aktuellen Versionen davon mehr.
Guck mal, die KVM.
Guck mal, hier ist es.
Der Maus-Lag, wisst ihr was?
Der Maus-Lag im BIOS, der liegt am BIOS und nicht irgendwie an der KVM.
Guck mal, wie schnell das hier jetzt ist.
Guck mal, die schwarze Maus da hinterher.
Seht ihr das?
Es ist kaum Verzögerung drin.
Kaum Verzögerung.
Das liegt am BIOS. Das BIOS ist einfach so laggy.
Laggy UEFI.
Mind bestimmt Krypto im BIOS.
Ganz ehrlich.
Das sind Minis Forum PC.
Der kommt aus China
Das kann ich mir durchaus vorstellen
Wahrscheinlich ist da auch ein Mikrofon drin
Oder sowas
Der erstmal alles aufzeichnet
Und versucht nach China
In die
In die Tuya Cloud oder so zu laden
Warum dann nicht
Da gab es doch letztens irgendwas
Es gab doch letztens wieder irgend so
Irgend so ein IoT Ding
Wo sich dann auch rausgestellt hat
Da ist ein Mikrofon mit dabei
Wo es keiner von wusste
Weiß jemand noch was das war
oder war das nicht sogar
eine KVM?
Die das hat. Irgendein Gerät, was
einige Leute am Start haben,
kam jetzt nachträglich raus. Ah, das hat ja ein Mikrofon
eingebaut.
Wusste keiner bis dahin.
Naja, nicht das SmartPrick.
Ja, genau das hier.
nano kvm ja researchers found china chinesen in der china chinesen kvm andock
an clearly documented microphone and communicates china based servers
exzellent genau das was man braucht hast du die ankündigung von euro office
mitbekommen ich habe heute irgendwas gelesen war
heise dass sie jetzt irgendwie die große oft genau irgendwie konkurrenz
offensive staaten und das habe ich auch gelesen dass in den usa alle router jetzt
verboten sind wenn sie nicht komplett in den usa gefertigt wurden
also das ist doch gerade mal während cash us installiert kann man es ja kurz
mal angucken.
IONOS, Nextcloud und weitere
Partner haben gemeinsam eine Quellen-Office
mit dem Namen Eurooffice,
die als Microsoft-Alternative gedacht ist.
Da müssten halt ein paar Leute mit richtig
fett Kohle mitmachen,
die da auch ein großes Interesse dran haben.
Keine Ahnung, SAP oder irgendwie sowas.
ansonsten bin ich mir nicht sicher was ich den ja libel zum beispiel libel
libel könnte auch mitmachen
Warte mal, was gibt es denn schon wieder für Vorwürfe?
Zersetzen die sich schon wieder, bevor es überhaupt losgegangen ist?
Naja
Warten wir mal ab
Ich mein, es wär ja wünschenswert, ne
Es wär ja durchaus wünschenswert
Wobei, ihr kennt mich
Ich bin ja kein großartiger Office-Nutzer
Dementsprechend
Tja
Aber mir ist es eigentlich ziemlich egal und ich glaube halt eines der Punkte, warum viele Leute Microsoft Office verwenden oder mehrere Punkte.
Der Hauptpunkt ist, weil sie nichts anderes kennen, weil es dabei ist und weil das Microsoft 365 Angebot mit den 2 Terabyte Speicherplatz in der Cloud und Dokumente überall bearbeiten und verfügbar, glaube ich auch viele überzeugt.
Also bis es da was vergleichbares gibt, europäisches, das wird noch ein bisschen dauern.
Und Excel. Ja, Excel sei es. Die IDE, da ist da Kriterien.
Wobei ich keine Ahnung habe, wie gut Calc mittlerweile ist.
So, dann booten wir mal
ein CacheOS rein.
Und installieren den Beta-Körnel.
Stop mounting.
Wir starten von
ähm, Chat.
Wo ist meine Festplatte zur Auswahl?
Ich würde ja gerne booten.
Die Frage ist, wie soll ich das denn machen?
Boot Option 4.
Harddisk.
Oder war ich blind?
Hab's nicht gesehen.
Ne, das ist die Samsung SSD.
Ja, wo ist denn...
Warum machen die das eigentlich immer so kompliziert, hä?
Boot.
Boot-Option.
Dann ist die erste Boot-Option jetzt...
Harddisk, okay?
In der Hoffnung, dass es jetzt von...
Monka...
W?
Dass es jetzt funktioniert.
äh
warum zum Teufel bootest du jetzt
von, von, von
Netzwerk
what
SS verwirrt
mich wieder hart
local boot
no local boot
geil
Pogsmog
sag mal, hat er das nicht gecheckt
dass er vor einer Festplatte booten soll?
Oder was ist das Problem jetzt?
Okay, müssen wir nochmal
ins Bios.
Ich glaube, das hat er nicht gecheckt.
Hat er vielleicht Probleme
von SATA zu booten?
Juckt ihn überhaupt nicht
Juckt ihn gar nicht
Okay
Das ist aber sehr dumm
Ja.
Das ist aber echt dumm.
Was mache ich jetzt?
Hm.
ähm
wir mounten uns mal wieder
das
Mount Image
wartet mal, die Kiste ist jetzt ja gestartet
hm
gehen wir mal kurz hier drauf und gucken mal
was er so findet
ähm
ich sehe es jetzt nicht mal fdisk minus l dev sd was haben wir da sda
was das
müsste usb sticks sein oder sowas
Ja, die ist die, die ist das
Ja, ne, guck hier
Ist eigentlich alles drauf
Ach, 24T
Ja, das ist die
Die fette, die geschockte Festplatte
Also hier ist alles drauf, guck
EFI-Partition
Ähm
Ich war es, ist nett
Ich weiß es nicht
Dann installieren wir nochmal neu
Und installieren es jetzt meinetwegen
Auf der einen SSD
Whatever
Auf guten Blitz
Gucken wir noch einmal
Hat sich nicht richtig im EFI registriert.
Ja, scheint so.
Sollen wir vielleicht anstatt Slimine
mal Crab nehmen?
Wir installieren es auf der SSD
und nehmen Crab.
Da kann jetzt wirklich nichts mehr schief gehen.
Das Install selbst hat ja auch noch 5 Minuten gedauert.
Du du du du du du du du
Man kann sogar...
Hab ich ein Video gesehen?
Doch, doch, doch, ich benutze Chattorino.
Ich habe ein Video gesehen, da hat irgendeiner einen Ray Tracer oder so gebaut in Excel.
Warte mal, YouTube.
Excel Ray Tracing.
Ach guck mal, es gibt eine neue CPU von Intel.
Hier, Ray Tracing in Excel.
Die sind schon total abgedreht, die Leute, oder?
Was man so in Excel treibt, ne?
Das ist auch, da sind wir erstaunlich ruckelfrei auch.
So, wir machen mal
Versus
13.900k, mal gucken.
Taugt diese Seite überhaupt was?
Keine Ahnung.
Sieht man da irgendwas?
Ich glaube, die
Okay, whatever.
Okay, Launch Installer.
Was?
Willst du mich verarschen?
Ah.
Ich weiß, was wir machen müssen.
Die Netzwerkkarte backt wieder rum, Leute.
Wir müssen Hard Power of Power On machen.
Ich stehe mal kurz auf und mache das.
Also, die Hardware von dem Nass ist ja eigentlich gut, ne?
Aber so diese Bugs, die sie da haben, was Firmware und so angeht, das ist schon nicht so geil.
Das war's für heute.
irgendwie ist mein ja war gerade ein bisschen am backen mein mikrofon ich habe so eine steckdose
aber jetzt halt ich müsste die steckdose ist das problem ich habe das ding an der usv stecken an
An der USV sind nur diese Kaltgerätestecker.
Da kriege ich keine Steckdose dazwischen.
Oder ich muss halt einen Stecker von diesem Kaltgerätestecker auf normalen Stecker,
die Steckdose dazwischen stecken und dann wieder da das Nass anstöpseln.
Alles nicht so dolle.
Oh Mist, ich habe vergessen.
Ich habe vergessen beim Booten Knopf zu drücken.
Bin ich noch schnell genug?
Hä?
Hallo?
Macht das was?
Nas?
Nas, lebst du noch?
Ähm
Hallo, Nass
Nass Champ
Hä?
Wer ist angeblich wieder da?
Wer ist wieder da?
Gar kein Problem
Aber mein Nass hat keinen Bock
Alter
Sag mal, kann da mal was funktionieren?
Please
Was ist das für ein Scheiß?
Wartet mal
Ich starte mal einen anderen Firefox
Ob er da jetzt mag
Advanced, ja ja
Proceed
Wie?
Hä?
Okay, keine Ahnung, was das
wieder für ein Scheiß ist, Alter.
Okay, reboot.
Ja, das genau.
Miepz.
Das müsste ich dann machen.
Ich müsste dann Kaltgerätestecker auf normalen Stecker machen.
Da müsste ich dann quasi
die Steckdose zum Schalten reinstecken.
Dann dort wiederum das NAS.
Naja.
Pass mal auf, jetzt ist die Festplatte drin.
Ne, shit.
Wäre auch zu einfach gewesen, oder?
Mal gucken, ob wir jetzt wenigstens Internet
Access haben.
By the way,
Chat, warum brauche ich überhaupt
Internet Access, um CacheOS zu installieren?
Na gut, das ist so
Das muss ich ja sich Sachen während Installation wahrscheinlich runterladen.
The Edge Verification.
Ja.
das schlimme an dem gag ist das ist gar nicht so weit hin kann ich so weit her geholt
mittlerweile was eigentlich jeden tag auf weitere solcher news
Ich sag euch, dauert nicht mal lang, dann kommen die wieder mit Klarnamenpflicht im
Internet und so nem Scheiß um die Ecke.
Arsch aufs Nass, ja.
Vielleicht löst das meine Performance-Probleme mit der Netzwerkkarte.
Das wäre sehr nice.
Dann weiß ich zumindest, dass ich die Sachen demnächst mit nem neuen Kernel erledigen.
Okay, geht das Internet jetzt oder nicht?
So, wir wollen...
Wie war das? American English,
war mal. American English.
German.
Next.
Grupp.
Ja, meinetwegen
da drauf. Ist okay.
Erase Disk.
Efi System.
also das sollte der 1 sollte jetzt eigentlich so funktionieren bravo mike
dankeschön für den sub
max omega pok elke was auch immer das bedeuten soll
So, next.
Install.
Was macht der eigentlich für ein standardmännisches
Filesystem jetzt drauf?
Äh.
Steht das irgendwo?
Chat, bin ich blind?
Weiß man nicht, oder?
BTFS?
Wo steht das? Wo steht das? Bin ich blind?
Ach hier, install Cache aus der
New BTFS System Partition.
Ah.
Soll mir recht sein.
Mach halt BTFS.
Okay.
Install.
So, ich beiße noch mal kurz in mein Toastbrot.
Schlitzer.
Dankeschön.
Für den Sub.
Schlitzer.
Hast du früher MW2 gespielt?
Marathon Lightweight Commando?
Das passt irgendwie zu dem Namen.
Ich bin gestern 11,2 Kilometer gerannt.
Das war gesund genug.
Ähm.
Ich weiß nicht, ob wir das heute schaffen.
Das hängt davon ab,
wie sehr sich das noch sträubt
beim Installieren.
Aha.
Foxmox does not boot.
Was war das Problem?
Da ist er.
Das hat...
Okay.
Was auch immer.
Muss man nicht verstehen.
Auf CacheOS, mach hin.
Privacy and Security.
Ich kann wetten, das funktioniert jetzt.
Ansonsten habe ich keinen Bock mehr.
Damit Rage quittet.
Es wäre natürlich trotzdem nice, wenn es funktioniert
Gab es da nicht so ein Tool
Wo man
EFI
Einträge im BIOS anlegen kann
Irgendwie EFI Boot MGR
Oder sowas hieß das doch
konnte man quasi selbst anlegen was da in diesem bp menü drin steht weil das professional also
zwei gründe das professional braucht ganze ecke mehr strom im eitel und hat wohl probleme mit
dem sata controller haben viele leute schon von file system corruption berichtet
und dann wie starten
mini forum bringt bestimmt firmen wir haben ja da ist ja mini
vor bekannt dafür immer besonders viele firmen abblend zu bringen
Haben die für irgendein Produkt jemals schon Firmware-Updates...
Ich weiß, wie du es meinst, aber es ist dir bekannt, ob die überhaupt jemals schon mal für irgendwas Firmware-Updates released haben.
Aha.
Da ist es, CashUS.
Äh.
Hallo?
Was habe ich jetzt falsch gemacht?
Okay.
Falsches Menü.
Machen wir mal Fullscreen.
Ja, da sind wir.
Bam.
Okay, also Terminal.
Boah sieht das Standard Terminal hässlich aus, Alter.
aber das auch irgendwas machen mit dem hintergrund nicht so durchsichtig ist
naja bitte bitte soll mir recht sein also
was haben die da alles für zeug vorinstalliert man ich will jetzt pacman
N-S IPerf3.
Heißt das so?
Yes.
Also, IPerf3.
IP-Ads.
So, was haben wir für eine IP gekriegt?
1, 2, 1. Okay.
IPerf3-S.
Was? 1, 2, 1.
Hä?
Chat.
Ist da eine Firewall an? Kann das sein?
Da stand nämlich Firewall an, hä?
Firewall.
Die schalten wir jetzt einfach aus.
Yes. Weg damit.
Excellent. Beste Firewall ist Disable the Firewall.
Okay.
Das ist ja schon mal vielversprechend.
Äh.
Alter, diese Netzwerkkarte.
Ich weiß aber, was das Problem ist.
Das hatte ich schon mal.
Man muss komplett ausschalten.
Hier, guckt mal.
Man muss komplett ausschalten, Strom ausmachen.
Und dann wieder neu starten.
Und dann geht es wahrscheinlich.
Was machen wir jetzt?
Stand da Placingly Fast gerade?
Habe ich das richtig gesehen?
Stand da CachyOS Blazingly Fast?
Das gefällt den Krustentieren aber bestimmt nicht.
Weil nur Rust Software ist Blazingly Fast.
Okay, Chat.
Ich ziehe den Stecker und mache nochmal neu ab.
Oh, ich bin zu lahm.
Entfernen, entfernen, entfernen.
Okay, Endring, set up, nice.
Also die eine Richtung war ja schon mal sehr schnell.
Laza.
Hat das irgendwas mit Fußball zu tun?
Nein.
Dann weiß ich nicht, was das sein soll.
Ja.
CashUS
Grupp
Ne, schon eine ganze Weile
nichts mehr gehört
Aber ich hab's ja auch wieder verkackt
Ihr kennt mich ja, wie ich bei so sozialen Dingern bin
Ich hätt mich ja auch mal melden können
habe ich aber nicht gemacht.
Weil ich Kack-Knub-Keller-Kent bin.
Ist es jetzt kaputt
irgendwie?
Mein Cash-EOS?
Nee. Boah, ich war schon kurz
davor zu ragen.
Weil es
das Leben wieder schwer macht.
Jaja, hat er, hat er gepackt.
So, Konsole.
Und ich wohne immer noch in Frankfurt, ja.
IPerf 3 minus S.
Okay, jetzt nochmal testen.
Aha.
Okay, man muss jetzt mal ehrlicherweise sagen,
es ist deutlich konstanter
als auf der anderen Kiste.
Also ich würde schon sagen,
die Änderungen im Treiber,
also im Kerneldreiber,
die haben sich gelohnt.
Das ist auf jeden Fall besser
als vorher.
War es jetzt die Plate oder der Loader?
Keine Ahnung. Wir können mal gucken, wenn man
beides gleichzeitig macht.
Und wir müssen noch eine VM installieren jetzt
auf Cache.
Was geht da zum Glück halbwegs schnell?
Na gut, Bidirectional ist wohl nicht so die Stärke von dem Ding.
Wann sieht man dich in Frankfurt der Tinder-Videos?
Du kannst mich, du hättest mich, also wenn du wüsstest, wie ich aussehe,
hättest du mich auf Fotos vom letzten GP Morgenlauf gesehen.
Aber ich bin damit zufrieden
Also die Performance
Warte mal, ich hab's falsch rum
Äh, hallo?
WF, was jetzt?
Das R muss da vorne
Aber das ist jetzt okay
Ich mein, die Performance könnte trotzdem immer noch ein bisschen schneller sein
Beste ist es immer noch nicht
8,8
8,2
Also es könnte durchaus noch so 600 Mbit oder so schneller sein.
Aber es ist jetzt auf jeden Fall wenigstens schön konstant.
Jetzt müssen wir noch eine VM da drauf installieren.
Wie macht man das jetzt am schnellsten?
Vor allem mit Kishi als Wirt-Manager, oder?
Also erstmal muss ich ZSH starten, sonst kriege ich Anfälle.
Was?
Das ist do nothing.
Huch.
Und jetzt?
Boah, das ist ja...
Das ist ja eine der ekligsten Sachen hier, die ich da bisher gesehen habe.
Kann man das denn ordentlich größer machen?
Wenn du Marathon läufst, hast du wahrscheinlich viel abgenommen.
Ich habe viel abgenommen, aber ich laufe keinen Marathon.
Ich glaube, das längste, was ich bisher gelaufen bin, waren irgendwie 17 Kilometer oder sowas.
Also mein Ziel ist, dass ich ja mal irgendwann Halbmarathon-Distanz packe.
das sind irgendwie so was was ich 21 kilometer so in dem dreh packe und das in einem brauchbaren
tempo für mich ich brauche mir gar nichts ich probiere gerade raus zu kriegen warum
meine Netzwerkkarte so langsam ist.
Okay, wir installieren
uns jetzt...
Wir installieren uns jetzt
Wirtmanager.
Was braucht man dafür alles?
Wirtmanager, LibWirt?
Oder installiert das schon
alles mit?
Hat das LibWirt und so mit installiert?
By the way, die Auflösung macht es hier fertig.
Ja, LibWirt ist installiert. Okay, nice.
Mal gucken, ob das...
Systemctl Start LibWirt.
Okay.
WirtManager.
Wirt.
Okay.
Welchen Kunden?
Heftig rum.
Wirt.
Das war doch Wirt Manager, oder?
Okay.
Ja, ja.
Ah, KVM ist nicht installiert.
Kann das sein?
Kann sein, dass KVM fehlt.
Add Connection.
UEMO KVM.
Nö.
KVM ist am Start.
Okay.
Moment, wie geht das jetzt?
New.
Was installiere ich denn jetzt? Ich installiere ein Debian.
Debian Stable. Das geht am schnellsten.
Moment, Moment. Ich kann doch mal mein PXE installieren.
Easy.
No hypervisor options were found.
It's not installed.
Okay, was muss ich dafür?
QEMU KVM oder was muss ich dafür installieren?
Libvirt.
QEMU KVM.
Ups.
Jetzt habe ich irgendwie meinen Terminal.
Ah, wir sind ja immer noch im Browser.
das hat mich jetzt...
Ja, ja, ja, ich hab Wobblos verlängert.
Moment, was muss man?
How to install QEMU
Arch QEMU KVM.
Ich hab da schon eine andere Karte
eingebaut zum Testen. Damit ging das.
Das war das allererste, was ich gemacht hab.
Checking KV... Sag mal, kann man nicht
die Bitrate
von der KVM irgendwie ein bisschen höher
stellen? Das pixelt mir zu sehr.
Wo kann man denn hier Bitrate einstellen?
Mode Smart.
Was ist Mode Normal?
Quality High.
Mal gucken, ob das jetzt besser ist.
Pixel ist jetzt weniger.
Jetzt hängt es.
Noch viel geiler.
Darf ich jetzt?
Ja, ich darf jetzt.
Ja, ich finde es auch gut, dass ich wieder mehr strebe.
Das macht halt immer Bock.
So.
Also, was brauche ich denn jetzt für...
Also, erstmal checken, ob wir KVM supporten.
Okay, machen wir.
Anscheinend unterstützen wir KVM.
Was muss ich denn jetzt alles...
Was muss ich denn installieren dafür?
Auto-Use KVM.
QEMU full.
Sollen wir installieren.
Okay.
QEMU full.
Alles klar.
Bam.
Ich mach das jetzt einfach mal.
Arch-Wiki eh beste.
So.
Wirthmanager.
Darf ich jetzt?
Was bringt es, dass du deine Netzwerkkarte nicht 400 MHz...
Ich will, dass die Karte so ungefähr 600-700 Mbit mehr überträgt.
Da kann man einfach Sachen schneller kopieren beispielsweise.
Stell dir vor, du hast irgendwo einen Windows-Share und kopierst eine große Datei von A nach B.
Das geht halt einfach schneller.
Außerdem nervt es mich, dass sie theoretisch 10 Gigabit packt, aber nur 8,8 gerade hinbekommt.
Was sagen wir mal so, 9,5 Gigabit.
Wirklich 10 Gigabit packt der eigentlich nichts.
Okay, jetzt geht das hier.
Local Install.
Manual Install.
x86, x64.
Choose Operating System.
Was kann man da?
Kann man da irgendwas aus?
Ubuntu.
Keine Ahnung, ist mir doch egal.
Ne, Debian, Debian installieren wir.
Debian 13, next.
Memory
CPUs 5
Das ist okay.
Network
Bridge
Mac VTab
ist dieses Bridge-Ding ohne Bridge.
Richtig?
Also da gebe ich jetzt an,
ENS-Dings.
Ich habe das schon lange nicht mehr gemacht hiermit.
So, irgendwie in der Richtung.
Finish. Gucken wir mal, ob das funktioniert.
PXE.
No bootable device found.
Er soll PXE booten.
man die kvm spackt rum
ja ein bisschen verlust ist immer was ist jetzt hier
ach der hat meine tastatur gecaptured deswegen
wie stellt man den kvm eigentlich richtig ein dass der euch das so lange nicht mal benutzt
Alter. Ähm, dass der
jetzt Netzwerkboot macht. Hier irgendwo?
Boot Options? Boot Options.
Hier. Enable Bootmenü.
Wir
enablen das Bootmenü. Das ist gut.
Bootmenü enablen.
Run.
Escape.
Oh ne.
Okay.
IPXE please.
Haha ein pxe ist am start also debian installer install
Bin ich froh dass das pxe ding hier am start habe dieses ganze seitdem brauche ich dieses
Dieses ganze dumme iso gelade und so nicht mehr so wir installieren stable wir installieren das auf der ersten disk
perfekte hausnahme
Highspeed Debian Installation.
So, jetzt sollte er von der Platte eigentlich einen Debian tun.
Ging das nicht schnell, Leute? Ist das nicht nice mit dem PXE-Server?
Das müsst ihr doch echt mal zugeben, oder?
Das ist mega nice. Wie schnell man sich da einen Debian draufklatschen kann, ist schon enorm pock.
Ja, ich spiele regelmäßig Sachen auf Steam.
Ich spiele allerdings wenig Battlefield und sowas in letzter Zeit.
Also die letzten Call of Duties haben mich komplett kalt gelassen.
Habe ich mir gar nicht mehr gekauft.
Also ich glaube seit dem...
Seit Cold War.
Also Cold War habe ich mir auch nicht mehr gekauft.
Ab Cold War habe ich nicht mehr gekauft.
Ne, ne.
Das letzte größere Game war Expedition 33, was ich gespielt habe.
Also was man so kennt.
So, äh, SSH.
Äh, Leute, ich hab ein Problem.
Ich würde gerne...
Ich würde gerne hier rauskommen.
Was muss ich denn für eine Taste drücken,
dass ich hier rauskomme?
Eben hab ich's doch schon mal geschafft, oder?
Wirt-Manager.
Exit
Free Keyboard
Okay, was muss man drücken?
Control
Plus Control Right
Was?
Control Alt
Das habe ich eben ein paar mal gedrückt
Das hat nichts gebracht
Ich drücke Control Alt
Passiert nichts
Toolbox, kann ich hier auch nochmal machen
Kann man hier irgendwie sagen, dass wir irgendwie eine Tastatur bekommen zum Drücken?
Diese dummen, diese scheiß Sachen hier, die machen mich immer...
Okay, wisst ihr was?
Wir gehen jetzt hier einfach raus.
SSH 117 ist es, ne?
Wir gehen einfach per SSH drauf.
deviant oh nee meine ssh key vor der neuen kiste ist ja da noch nicht drin
es gibt immer probleme die soll es eigentlich gar nicht geben
ok easy easy easy mode ganz einfach hier so
So.
Vm wäre...
Okay, Vm starten.
Das macht am Echten das Leben schwer, ja?
Was für eine Vm nutzt du?
Oder nutzt du deine KVM?
Ne.
Ich hab...
Du meinst jetzt zum...
Moment.
Was meinst du jetzt?
auf dem Server, wo wir eben waren.
Was ist denn das hier jetzt?
Auf dem Server, wo wir eben waren.
Und du meinst das Cache-OS
auf dem Mini-PC.
Okay.
Wir gucken gleich.
Okay, da sind wir.
Also, Chat.
Upt, Install,
IPerf.
So, Chat, wir brauchen jetzt einmal
einmal ganz kurz
Pregel.
Prager. Wir brauchen Prager in den Chat, dass der Bug von dem Netzwerktreiber in VMs behoben ist. Prager.
Wir brauchen mindestens, mindestens 5 Pragers. Okay, haben wir. Bam.
Jetzt schauen wir mal.
Prager.
1, 1, 7.
Fuck!
Prager hat nichts geholfen. Der Bug ist im neuesten Kernel immer noch drin.
Dass der Speed in VMs nur noch halb so groß ist
Das kann man nur mit dem Hersteller eigenen Treiber fixen
Fuck
Oh, ich hab gedacht, neuer Treiber, äh, neuer Kernel, alles gut
Okay, äh, bist du noch da?
Wie hieß er?
Orge, bist du noch am Start?
Dann kann ich dir zeigen, wie das funktioniert mit der, mit der VM
Nicht mit der Linux-Kiste
Boah, was ein Scheiß, Alter
Bringt ja überhaupt nichts
Okay, okay
Also, die Cache-US-Kiste hier meinst du, ne?
Wie gesagt, nicht zu verwechseln mit dieser Cache-US-Kiste
Also, diese Cache-US-Kiste, die du hier siehst, da bin ich per KVM drauf
Auf der Cache-US-Kiste hier, die ist auf dem Mini-PC
die hier kann die hier kannst du ignorieren ja ich nur das einfach das war gerade das
nass wo ich drauf war und das ausprobieren wollte die cash us kiste hier das ist ein
mini pc und zwar ein beelink sr 7 dieses teil hier ich bin mir gar nicht sicher was da was
an cpu drin ist ok in den reisen acht kerne radian 780 m also und und aktuell aktuell leider nur 8
g da läuft das cash us drauf so und wie das cash us hier auf den auf den bildschirm kommt ist
folgendermaßen ich habe mir capture card eingebaut in meinem desktop pc und die capture card capture
einfach den output von meinem mini pc und zeigt mir an also das was du hier eigentlich siehst
ist ein obs im fullscreen cook zweiter desktop erster desktop zweiter deshalb zweiter desktop
obs im fullscreen deswegen dass das sieht nur so aus ja letztendlich ist es ein obs im fullscreen
der den hdmi output von dem mini pc capture hat und das geht nahezu latenzfrei also ich bin da
sehr zufrieden mit dem setup gefällt mir auch besser als die vm weil es echte hardware ist
und man hat auch so sachen wie gpu acceleration für videos benutzen kann und so was ich finde
es echt gut ist natürlich ein bisschen würde man sagen ein bisschen wirklich ja du brauchst
desktop pc daneben braucht capture card muss das alles einstellen und maus und
tastatur sharing ein das ist eine elgato 4k pro pc express capture card main pc
auf windows wegen stream und spielen ja wegen streamen wegen spielen wegen video
editing und thumbnails machen und sowas
Wobei ich mir relativ sicher bin, dass ich mittlerweile das meiste auch unter Linux machen könnte.
Außer ich will halt mal ein Spiel spielen mit Anti-Cheat.
Dann nicht.
Ich habe halt eine Nvidia-Grafikkarte.
Das ist ja eh schon auch nicht so geil.
Video-Editing.
Hast du nicht mal in den letzten 20 YouTube-Videos gesehen?
Innerhalb von einer Woche.
Also, wie läuft der Input?
Der Input läuft folgendermaßen.
Warte mal.
Ich habe hier ein Programm, das nennt sich Deskflow.
DaVinci Resolve
Ich höre, ich habe eigentlich zum größten Teil
Gutes über DaVinci Resolve gehört
Aber ich könnte mir vorstellen, dass das abartig ist
Bis man sich mal an den Workflow gewöhnt hat
Wie bei allen Videoprogrammen
Ja, also ich habe hier so ein Programm
Das nennt sich Deskflow
Gibt es auf GitHub, kostet nichts
Das ist ein Fork oder eine Weiterentwicklung von Synergy
Kennt ihr noch Synergy?
Das war so eine Maus-Tastatur-Sharing-Sache
Die es schon seit 20 Jahren oder so gibt
Sehen wir weiter Entwicklung von Synergy.
Und das habe ich hier auf dem Desktop.
Und das habe ich hier laufen auf der Linux-Kiste.
Und so mache ich Tastatur-Sharing.
Maus-Tastatur-Sharing.
Hat man verstanden, oder?
Ach, zum Installieren soll es Pain sein.
Das können wir doch gerade mal ausprobieren.
Wie installiert man denn DaVinci Resolve?
Hier, guck mal, gibt es mal CacheUS sogar dabei
Das probieren wir jetzt einfach mal
Clipboard
Clipboard macht
Deskflow auch
Allerdings aktuell geht das nur
in eine Richtung
Ich glaube, es geht nur von
Windows Host auf die Linux Kiste
nicht umgedreht
Das liegt aber an Wayland
Probieren wir nochmal aus, ob DaVinci Resolve
so Painstamp ist
Warum ist das so langsam?
Ne, das ist gar nicht so langsam.
Das ist einfach nur groß as fuck.
Kann das sein?
Das Programm ist einfach nur ein paar Gigabyte groß.
Okay, wir starten trotzdem
nochmal schnell neu.
In der Hoffnung nimmt er einen anderen Mirror.
Hä, ist auch nicht schneller.
Das Programm ist einfach nur groß.
Guck mal.
Einfach nur ein bisschen.
Ey, aber 2 Minuten.
zwei Minuten haben wir auch noch. Das geht schon.
Du-du-du-du-du-du-du-du-du-du-du.
Ähm.
Moment. Wir gehen noch mal kurz hier aufs Nass drauf.
Mal 44.
Punkt 144.
Darf ich jetzt auf der Kiste auch?
Ja. Alles. Und jetzt
machen wir
stop mounting toolbox control alt entfernen checkt das cash ios eigentlich control alt delete
oder cash ios check kein control alt delete und raus tappen aus meiner ich
bin gefangen leute raus tappen aus der vm kann ich auch nicht ich kann höchst ich bin gefangen leute
hier dass das geht okay okay okay reboot
keine ahnung habe ich nie ausprobiert
sub gift wenn es instant startet ich würde von ausgehen dass es
sind schon startet ehrlich gesagt sag mal was sind das für mir aus hier
wollen mich veräppeln der fach der braunheit sind brauner ewig moment
moment moment ich muss mal kurz mal quack essen
er joghurt
es geht schnell
jetzt flutscht die gucken die betreiber gucken bestimmt stream und haben jetzt extra bandbreite
gegeben.
Die haben gesagt, wenn der
Wubblos runterlädt über unseren Mirror
und es langsam ist, das geht ja nicht.
Ich bin mal gespannt. Also,
ehrlich gesagt, ich gehe davon aus, dass es
jetzt problemlos direkt startet.
Würde ich jetzt
von ausgehen.
Pop OS?
Da bist du der erste, von dem ich höre,
der Pop OS installiert hat und dann
auch da quasi gestickt ist.
Was spricht aus deiner Sicht
für Pop OS?
Wissen Sie, dass ich fast mal einen Burger Sponsoring gekriegt habe?
2011 oder so.
Kostenloser Burger für Twitter Werbung.
der fette bulle in frankfurt war das freeburger
jedoch
guck da da wünschen wir sollten
da ist
ich habe keine ahnung wie es funktioniert aber scheint zu laufen
ob jetzt auf dem er noch
Das probiere ich bestimmt nicht.
Außerdem habe ich gar kein Debian mit GPU.
Also ich würde es ja sogar ausprobieren,
aber ich habe kein Debian mit GPU.
Schlitzor,
danke schön für den Sub.
Wenn du bei deinem nächsten Video
nicht Cross-Sellout machst,
Du meinst, ich soll nochmal erzählen, dass ich noch nie in einer Wüste war?
Ich war nie in einer Wüste.
Oh, dieses Sponsoring.
Das ist so painstrap.
Moment.
Für alle, die es nicht kennen.
Jetzt könnt ihr mal gleich meine...
meine
Sponsoring skills sehen
Was man auf meine sponsoring skills keiner keiner liest werbetexte so gut vor wie ich
kannte ich so noch nicht
Haltet euch fest.
Besseres Sponsoring habt ihr noch nie gesehen.
Das bringt mich auch zum Partner des heutigen Videos.
Genshin Impact ist ein Open World Adventure Game mit einer großen Anzahl verschiedener Charaktere im Anime Style.
Genshin Impact ist für PS5, PS4, PC, auch für Mobilgeräte, iOS und Android erhältlich.
Die große atmosphärische offene Welt lädt dich ein, tiefer zu erforschen.
Eine Welt voller Geheimnisse, in der es sieben Regionen, sieben Götter und wie könnte es anders sein,
auch sieben Elemente gibt, die kombiniert werden können, um neue Synergien zu schaffen und noch mehr coole Angriffe auszuführen.
Die geschlossene Karte von Genshin, wenn man nur Mondstadt-Leo-Sumero mitzählt, ist mehr als 5.900 Fußballfelder in der realen Welt.
Das Spiel hat regelmäßige Inhaltsupdates wie den kürzlich veröffentlichten Patch 3.1, der neue aufregende Regionen wie Sumero mit einem neuen Wüstengebiet bringt.
Ich war noch nie in einer Wüste, aber ich kann die geheimnisvolle Wüste, die alten Ruinen in Sumero erkunden.
Und es gibt drei neue Helden im Spiel.
Sino, ein 5-Sterne-Elektro, Kanons, ein 4-Sterne-Hydro, beide recht mächtig.
und schließlich Nilou, ein 5-Sterne-Hydro, recht mächtig mit einem Schwert.
Zusätzlich zu den liebevoll gestalteten Anime-Visuals bietet jeder Charakter
seine eigene spannende Hintergrundgeschichte und eine möglichst tiefgreifende Interaktion mit der Spielwelt.
Zur Feier des Updates auf Version 3.1 zeigt Genshin Impact die Geschichte der Spieler in Genshin
in Offline-Werbung auf der ganzen Welt.
In Deutschland werden die Erinnerungsspieler im Münchner Hauptbahnhof gezeigt.
Ich empfehle euch also einen Blick darauf zu werfen, wenn ihr in der Nähe seid.
Scanne den QR-Code oder sieh dir meinen Download-Link zum Spiel zum Endless Journey Event in der Beschreibung an.
Wenn du diesen Code im Spiel verwendest, kannst du auch zusätzliche Belohnungen erhalten.
Vielen Dank an Genshin Impact für das Sponsoring des heutigen Videos.
So, genug Waifu-Alarm, jetzt geht's weiter mit Battleground.
Also ich würde sagen, recht mächtig, oder?
Ist gekauft.
Aber doch, keiner macht solche Sponsorings besser als ich, ey
Die wollten das, ey, by the way
Nicht, dass ihr denkt, ich hab das absichtlich schlecht gemacht
Die wollten das so
Das muss ich jetzt nochmal betonen an der Stelle
Ich wollte das nicht so
Ursprünglich war das so
Ich hab was zusammen
Gebastelt
Mit nem eigenen Text von mir
Der sich relativ
Flüssig angehört hat
da habe ich das denen gezeigt da haben die gemeint ja aber die und die und die und die punkte fehlen noch
nimm doch unseren text so dann habe ich den text runter gerattert und in das video geschickt haben gesagt super
Was hat okay wenn euch das lieber ist dann machen wir es halt so
Ich jetzt nicht nur dass ich absichtlich schlecht gemacht hätte oder so
Die wollten das explizit in schlecht
Ey gut, ich mein, die wollten halt
wirklich jeden
Einzelnen ihrer Punkte da drin haben.
Und das packst du halt nicht
in eineinhalb Minuten.
Wenn du nicht so super
runterratterst.
Das ist ein Kramer.
Naja.
Kickweight, Alter.
Gut, ähm,
Chat.
Haben wir jetzt was gelernt aus der ganzen Sache? Ja, wir haben was gelernt und zwar haben wir gelernt, dass auch Kernel 7 uns nicht rettet.
Was heißt, wir brauchen gezwungenermaßen weiterhin diesen blöden Netzwerktreiber vom Hersteller.
Ich habe ja sogar eine hier, die ich einbauen könnte
Aber ich will die Onboard-Netzwerkkarte
Verwenden, aus zwei Gründen
Oder sagen wir so, aus mehreren Gründen
Der hauptsächliche Grund ist aber
Wenn ich die Onboard-Netzwerkkarte
Verwende, habe ich den PCI-Express-Slot
Frei, um da noch irgendwas anderes einzubauen
Ich weiß jetzt noch nicht was
Aber ich sehe es nicht ein
wenn ich eine Kiste mit einer eigentlich ganz brauchbaren 10 Gig Onboard-Netzwerkkarte habe,
dass ich meinen PC-Express-Slot opfere für eine andere Netzwerkkarte.
Das sehe ich einfach nicht ein.
Außerdem ist die Netzwerkkarte, die drin ist, was den Stromverbrauch angeht, sehr gut.
Also sie braucht so gut wie kaum was.
Und das für eine Kupfer-AJ45-Netzwerkkarte.
Aber ich sehe es nicht ein.
Ich sehe es nicht ein.
Ich will die Onboard-10-Gig-Netzwerkkarte benutzen.
Du meinst, ich soll so lange, bis der Kernel gefixt ist, eine andere Netzwerkkarte einbauen?
Das mache ich nicht. Weißt du, warum?
Weil ich mich kenne, wenn ich einmal eine Netzwerkkarte eingebaut habe.
Und das läuft. Ich werde nie wieder eine andere Netzwerkkarte einbauen.
Und ob das jemals im Kernel gefixt sein wird,
sei mal dahingestellt.
Ich glaube, das hat noch nie einer als Bug überhaupt reportet.
Wir könnten ja mal einen Bug reporten
für den R8169-Treiber.
Kernel-Bug reporten und uns flamen lassen,
weil wir irgendwas nicht richtig gemacht haben.
Das mache ich nicht jetzt.
Ich würde bevorzugen,
dass es einfach geht.
Aber ist halt nicht so.
Ach so, was sagt eigentlich...
Das muss ich gerade mal gucken. Wartet mal.
Das interessiert mich jetzt.
Was sagt eigentlich jetzt der ZFS-Pool
dazu,
dass ich auf ein Laufwerk...
Ah, cannot import.
Ah, der hat schon importiert.
Okay, wie auch immer.
Was sagt denn jetzt eigentlich ZFS dazu,
dass seine Platte fehlt?
Ah, guck mal.
Der hat es erkannt.
Ups.
Ah ne, im Moment ist der andere Pool
Ja, guck mal, der hat es erkannt
Der hat erkannt, dass
Ähm, die 1TB Platte
Weggeflogen ist
Also die ist ja nicht wirklich
Weggeflogen, da habe ich
Casual erst drauf installiert
Das hat er gleich gecheckt
So, gehen wir noch hin
So, jetzt machen wir nochmal ein Netzwerk
ähm, äh, nicht Netzwerk,
ne, ne,
Disk-Benchmark und ist immer noch schnell.
Kaputt gemaxed, ja.
Oh, ich wurde letztens kontrolliert, Leute,
in der Bahn und das war so ein Überkorrekter.
Den hab ich, dem hab ich
mein Deutschland-Ticket gezeigt in der App.
Hat er gemeint, ja, er hätte bitte
noch den Ausweis. Hab ich gesagt, äh,
ich hab heute keinen Rucksack dabei, ich hab keinen Ausweis
dabei. Ich kann Ihnen das Geburtsdatum
sagen. Ja, gehen Sie mal in Ihre
Handy-Einstellung. Bin ich in meine Handy-Einstellung?
Einstellung, da stand dann Max, bla bla bla
drin in den Settings.
Und da meinte der, ah, das sind sie aber nicht.
Wie, das bin ich nicht? Natürlich ist das der gleiche Name
wie auf dem Deutschland-Ticket.
Nein, ihr Name hat eigentlich
acht Buchstaben.
Oder neun Buchstaben, oder irgendwas hat er gesagt.
Neun Buchstaben, glaube ich.
Neun Buchstaben hat er gesagt.
Ja.
Wie jetzt?
Achso, da habe ich gesagt, achso, ja klar.
Max, aber ich heiß halt
Maximilian, ja, also Deutschland-Ticket
ist halt Maximilian drauf und im Handy
Einstellungschnitt Max. Und dann meinte er, ah, okay,
klingt logisch, okay, passt.
Dann nehmen sie doch das nächste Mal
den Ausweis mit.
Ja, ja.
Die sollen immer alle nicht so auf den Sack gehen.
Die haben jetzt auch, was ich witzig finde,
die haben jetzt, aber witzig, witzig finde ich es nicht,
das war vielleicht falsch ausgedrückt, ja.
Ich finde es eher bedenklich,
dass es notwendig ist, die haben mittlerweile alle
Bodycams.
Alle Borde...
Also alle...
Irgendeine GoPro oder so dran.
Nachdem es so viele Angriffe auf Bahnmitarbeiter gab.
Ich erschleich mir Leistung, indem ich ein Ticket hab.
Logisch.
Hey Max, möchte mir mein Passwortmanager jetzt runter von der...
Was? Moment, das muss ich nochmal neu lesen.
Hey Max, möchte mir meinen Passwortmanager jetzt runter von...
Achso.
Da fehlt ein Wort, oder?
Du möchtest jetzt den eigenen Passwortmanager quasi betreiben und willst weg von der Cloud.
Hast du eine Idee, was ich dafür nehmen soll, beziehungsweise was du nimmst?
Ich kann dir sagen, was ich nehme.
Willst du was haben mit Apps auf dem Handy, Browser Extensions und auch über einen Browser benutzbar, zugreifbar von mehreren Rechnern und sowas?
Oder willst du wirklich nur einen Passwort save?
also ich benutze kieper ich benutze das hier ich benutze kieper ich denke meine passwörter aber
auch nicht aufs handy oder so ja ich habe hier mein kieper sich eine backup vom kieper fertig
das reicht ich habe nichts aufs handy gesinkt an passwörtern und ich kann auch nicht per browser
darauf zugreifen oder irgendwie app oder sonst was also wenn du einfach nur ein passwort manager auf
deinem desktop rechner haben willst neben kippas fertig ansonsten ist wohl worden nicht verkehrt
hat auch den vorteil sollte man vielleicht jetzt auch mal erwähnen habe ich glaube ich so noch
nicht gesagt dadurch dass wohl worden die passwörter quasi auf einem anderen rechner
liegen könnte man sagen ist das ja sogar noch ein ticken sicherer weil wenn einer bei euch
irgendein rootkit installiert hat auf der windows kiste könnt ihr ja relativ
easy euer keypass zeug auslesen er hat einfach warten bis ihr euer passwort
eintipp mit sein und gut ist wenn das woanders liegt ist es schwieriger
letztendlich aber sobald den rootkit auf dem rechner habt auch über kurz oder
lang möglich die vault worden ist nicht die pre kate oder volt worden es ist
doch nichts die plik vor zwei tagen ist das hätte mich hätte mich auch echt gewundert
wenn das die plik hätte weil das ja eines der beliebtesten projekte die es so gibt
passport kenne ich nicht ganz ehrlich neuen passwort man schon traue ich nicht bis sie
mindestens 15 jahre alt sind und in der zeit nichts passiert ist
ja keksdose was was sind deine anforderungen an den
passwort manager wie gesagt wenn du einfach nur passwort manager willst dem
Keepers.
Ich sag bei mir, ich
finde Cloud-Lösung für Passwort-Manager
ist
vielleicht bequem,
aber
kommt mir nicht in die Tüte.
Wie loggst du dich unterwegs
ein ohne Passwörter? Das ist ganz
einfach. Bei den meisten Apps
loggt man sich einmal ein und bleibt dann eingeloggt.
Da muss man sich gar nicht
mehrfach einloggen. Wie oft musstest du
dich bei Amazon einloggen in der App?
musste einmal machen wenn die app installiert und fertig so und die 23
passwörter die ich wirklich mobil brauche regelmäßig da fällt mir jetzt
so spontan noch nicht mal was ein so selten brauche ich die ja die habe ich
im iphone passwort save gespeichert aber eigentlich brauche ich da gar nichts und
alles was ich passwortmäßig authentifizieren muss muss ich einmal
beim app installieren authentifizieren dann ist gut
Ja, also
Das Problem habe ich nicht
Und wenn ich mich neu einloggen muss
Neue App
Dann mache ich das halt daheim
Wenn du von unterwegs drauf zugreifen willst
Dann wird es tatsächlich noch ein bisschen komplizierter
das naheliegende wäre,
ich sage aber auch gleich, dass ich es nicht unbedingt
empfehlen würde,
das naheliegende ist
natürlich ein Passwort-Safe, den du
von überall erreichen kannst. Das würde ich aber nicht machen.
Passwort-Safe gehört nicht
ins Internet, meiner Meinung nach.
Man kann da beliebig
tricksen, wenn überhaupt
und ich sage mal wirklich, wenn überhaupt,
dann nur per VPN.
Also mit dem Handy einloggen per VPN
und dann kann man quasi über dieses VPN auf den Passwortmanager mit Zugreifen,
braucht immer noch Masterpasswort.
Dann vielleicht, aber selbst davon halte ich jetzt persönlich nicht so viel.
Das Einfachste dürfte sein, wenn du dir überlegst,
also erstmal musst du dir überlegen, brauchst du wirklich alle Passwörter?
Willst du wirklich alle Passwörter mobil haben?
Weil potenziell ist natürlich auch,
Wenn du deine Passwörter erstmal auf dem Mobilgerät hast, sind sie erstmal außerhalb von deinen vier Wänden.
Das muss aber einfach klar sein, dass da einfach auch viel mehr Angriffsszenarien bestehen, als wenn die Passwörter auf deinem Desktop-Rechner daheim liegen.
Sobald die irgendwie das Haus verlassen.
Also überleg dir erstmal, ob du wirklich alle Passwörter mobil brauchst.
Gehen wir mal von aus, du sagst, ich brauche alle Passwörter mobil.
dann kannst du immer noch dein Passwort-Safe
synchen
geht auch mit KeyPass, KeyPass kannst du auch
synchen, aber mit Vault1
und den Apps ist tatsächlich besser
ähm
ansonsten
was ich persönlich auch ganz gut
finde ist, wenn du
Passwörter hast
wo du sagst, ok keine Ahnung, du hast ein Passwort-Safe
mit 300 Passwörtern drin, aber du brauchst
nur 5 dieser Passwörter mobil
muss dann wirklich der ganze Passwort-Safe
drauf gesynkt sein?
Willst du nicht vielleicht einen zweiten Passwort-Safe
machen und den synken nur dafür
für die Passwörter, die du mobil brauchst?
Willst du den nicht vielleicht
irgendwie
was weiß ich
in der App selbst mal abtippen
oder so, also ich meine, synken ist natürlich besser
aber alle Passwörter
synken, weiß ich, würde ich aufpassen
und weil die Leute
oftmals gesagt wird,
ja,
Smartphones sind sicher, wenn du die nicht,
wenn du da kein Passwort,
wenn du das Passwort nicht rausrückst oder Passwort nicht eingibst.
Will ich aber auf eine Sache hinweisen.
Ich glaube, die Chance,
dass irgendjemand, der an euer Handy
dran will,
euren PIN knackt,
ist relativ gering.
Aber,
wenn wir jetzt mal von ausgehen,
keine Ahnung,
Nehmen wir mal das Beispiel, irgendjemand fliegt, was sind denn so die üblichen Verdächtigen an Ländern, wo man sich Gedanken machen muss?
Nach China oder so, oder in die USA, oder nach Nordkorea, oder in irgendwelche südamerikanischen Länder, oder afrikanischen Länder, oder sonst was.
Ich stelle euch mal vor, ihr werdet da am Flughafen abgepasst.
Und ich gebe zu, okay, Chat, Chat, Kek-Alu-Warnung, ja?
Ich gebe zu, das ist ein bisschen Kek-Alu jetzt.
Bisschen, bisschen Kek-Alu.
Aber muss man, denke ich, trotzdem mal sagen.
Ich stelle euch vor, ihr werdet in einem dieser ganzen Shitländer abgepasst am Flughafen.
Und die sagen, ey, lassen sie uns auf ihr Smartphone gucken.
Und du sagst, nö.
Und dann denkt man so, ja dann können die ja nichts machen, weil nur wenn du denen das Passwort nicht gibst, dann lassen die dich dann irgendwann wieder frei und dann passiert nichts in der Richtung.
Das Problem ist jetzt, das aller einfachste an euer Passwort zu kommen ist nicht euer Handy zu knacken.
Das einfachste um euer Passwort zu kommen ist, einfach so lange auf euch einzuschlagen, bis ihr das Passwort freiwillig eintippt.
Ja, oder euch mit einer Zange die Finger kaputt schlagen, bis ihr euer Passwort mit der anderen Hand eingibt.
Also nur weil technische Möglichkeiten existieren, das sehr schwierig macht, etwas auszulesen,
heißt nicht, dass es da nicht einfachere Wege in solchen Ländern und Ecken der Welt gibt, ja.
und selbst wenn Face ID nicht geht.
Also man sollte sich nicht zu sehr auf
Technik verlassen.
Das Beste ist, und das ist das, worauf ich eigentlich
raus will,
das Beste ist,
man nimmt nur die Daten quasi mit
oder gibt nur die Daten raus,
die wirklich notwendig sind.
Weil sobald man Daten nicht rausgegeben hat,
kann auch nichts passieren.
Also mit rausgeben meine ich jetzt in irgendeine
Cloud laden, auf irgendein Gerät, was man mit raus
nimmt oder sowas.
Ich bin mir nicht sicher,
ob man das als eine Form von Social Engineering
betrachten kann.
OTP im Passwortmanager?
Ne, würde ich nicht machen.
Also, wenn man es mal genau nimmt, man untergräbt ja komplett den Sinn von Zwei-Faktor-Authentifizierung, wenn man Zwei-Faktor-Authentifizierung und Passwort mit der gleichen App macht.
Ja, also wenn man jetzt einen Passwortmanager hat
Mit dem gleichen Masterpasswort
Wenn man zweimal den Passwortmanager hat
Mit unterschiedlichen Masterpasswörtern
Lass ich mir ja noch gefallen, ja
Wobei das auf dem gleichen Gerät auch schon fragwürdig ist
Aber
Wenn man jetzt das gleiche Programm verwendet
Um
Zwei Faktor-Tokens zu generieren
Und die Passwörter
Naja, dann ist der Passwort-Safe weg, das Masterpasswort weg
Und der andere hat direkten Zugriff drauf
Weil er beides drin gespeichert ist
Also das würde ich nicht machen
Was ich aber wiederum machen würde, was meiner Meinung nach total unterschätzt wird, ist
Backup von 2-Faktor-Authentifizierungs-App.
Ich hatte selbst mal das Problem, ich habe das da, hieß das glaube ich, benutzt.
Das war eine recht beliebte 2-Faktor-Authentifizierungs-App.
und irgendwann wurde diese App verkauft
und der neue Besitzer der App hat ein Update gepusht
und auf einmal war die App hinter einer Subscription Wall
und du konntest nicht mehr auf deine Zwei-Faktor-Authentifizierungscodes zugreifen.
Damit sperrt man sich effektiv von ganz vielen Seiten aus.
Also, das muss einem klar sein,
sobald man Zwei-Faktor-Authentifizierung verwendet,
ist die Zwei-Faktor-Organisation genauso wichtig wie das Passwort.
Man darf das nicht verlieren.
Deswegen würde ich auf jeden Fall immer noch ein lokales Backup von diesen Sachen hier machen.
Mittlerweile habe ich Ente für OTP.
Das habe ich mittlerweile.
Ist EnterAuth vertrauenswürdig?
Hier lesen wir doch mal.
Was sagt denn Reddit dazu?
Ach, das ist wieder so ein hässlich übersetzter Thread.
Ja.
Das benutze ich mittlerweile.
Das finde ich auch ganz nice.
Und übrigens, hier, Chat, soll ich euch mal erklären, was ich hier gemacht habe?
Das war ein Riesenakt, ey.
Also das hier ist Schrott.
Auf gar keinen Fall benutzen, ne?
Die hatten auf einmal eine Subscription.
ein Subscription-Banner
und du konntest nicht mehr auf deine Passwörter zugreifen,
auf deine OTP zugreifen.
So.
Was ich gemacht habe ist,
ich hatte ja noch die App installiert
und ich hatte ja auch noch lokal
den Passwortsafe, also nicht den Passwortsafe,
den OTP-Safe liegen.
Was ich gemacht habe ist,
ich musste mir, oder besser gesagt, was ich machen musste ist,
ich musste mir
die, ich musste mir iTunes runterladen.
iTunes,
mein Handy anstöpseln,
Men in the Middle Proxy machen,
damit ich
einen Authentifizierungstoken bekomme.
Mit dem Authentifizierungstoken
konnte ich eine alte App-Version runterladen,
die dann über iTunes pushen.
So konnte ich die App downgraden.
Dann habe ich die App
downgegradet,
konnte meine Passwörter, also meine OTPs
wieder zugreifen, habe die einmal exportiert,
in EnterAuth
importiert und seitdem nie wieder
diese Schrott-App hier verwendet.
ente ist gut ja
kippers auch eigentlich nicht alle passwörter unterwegs aber haus ist so die kippers datenbank
auf einem externen gerät nass oder so oder auf deinem rechner ich mache das so ich habe die
kippers datenbank bei mir auf dem rechner liegen und ich mache regelmäßig backup von
ein paar Dateien auf mein NAS.
Da ist es dabei. Moin.
OC Bull for Fun.
Dankeschön für den Prime Sub.
Massive Subscription.
Wie kann es Schrott sein,
wenn da Best Authenticator steht?
Ey, Windows 11 ist auch das beste Windows, was es hier
gegeben hat, oder?
Ne, hab ich nicht gehört.
Aber was ich jetzt angefangen hab zu hören
als Audiobuch, das hat mir glaube ich
der RF-Programmer empfohlen,
ist
ähm
bei Audible.
Das da.
Kennt das jemand?
Ich hab noch nicht viel gehört,
aber allein schon der Anfang ist nice,
dass ich weiterhören will.
Also das, das, also
wie gesagt, ich hab vielleicht eine Stunde oder so gehört.
Also das ist mega nice.
Und es geht gleich am Anfang richtig gut
Ich spoiler nicht
Richtig gut los, wo du denkst, hä?
Warum verschwinden alle?
Warum, was ist los?
Doch, finde ich gut
Gefällt mir, exzellent
Ich hoffe auch
Aber Ente mache ich auch regelmäßige Backups
Achso irgendwo gab es noch die Frage
Wohin mit
Backup Keys
Oder diese Recovery Keys
Da habe ich leider keine gute Antwort drauf
Am besten wahrscheinlich noch einen zweiten extra Passwort Save
Dass man die zumindest getrennt speichert
Von seinen Hauptpasswörtern
oder aber, ganz ehrlich, auf den USB-Stick und in den Schrank legen oder eventuell sogar ausdrucken und in den Schrank legen.
Man muss ja immer sagen, der Zettel am Monitor ist viel besser als sein Ruf.
Früher wurde sich da immer lustig drüber gemacht, wenn die Oma gesagt hat,
oh, ich schreibe mir das Passwort jetzt auf den Zettel und hänge es am Monitor.
Dann hat man gesagt, ah Oma, das ist doch total unsicher und sowas.
Ist es gar nicht.
überlegt euch mal was ist für einen angreifer schwieriger wenn er sich irgendwie bei euch auf
dem rechner eingenistet hat euer passwort safe auslesen oder den zettel am monitor lesen mein
letztendlich wenn ein kilo gar am start hat dann kann er auch mit schneiden wenn ihr das passwort
eintippt aber nur mal so prinzipiell betrachtet was sichere es ist der zettel am monitor weil da
hast du mal so eine medien bruch dazwischen damit einer an eure passwörter
auf dem zettel gekommen zettel kommt muss er einbrechen bei euch oder ihr
habt so eine komische drohne mit kamera die rum fliegt oder der unter den
staubsauger mit kamera der nach oben gucken kann oder was auch immer
wenn er zettel mit den notfall passwörtern irgendwie im schrank liegt
dann muss schon einer bei euch einbrechen und das wird nicht passieren
es sei denn ihr habt probleme mit der polizei weil ihr irgendeine abwandlung
von Schwarzkopf oder so
zu einem Politiker auf Twitter geschrieben habt,
dann habt ihr Pech.
Aber die interessieren sich dann wahrscheinlich auch nicht für eure
One-Time-Passwörter.
Ja, in Büros würde ich jetzt mein Account-Passwort
nicht als Zettel hinhängen. Ich meine, daheim.
Bis zum nächsten Mal.
Gibt auch Passwortbücher mit random Zahlen.
Musst du ja nur eine Seite plus Zahlen...
So was gibt's?
Ist das nicht übelst unsicher?
Weil...
Also mal angenommen, ne?
Also mal angenommen, ein Passwort...
Also ich stell mir das jetzt so vor.
Ja, also...
Hallo, please, Mirror.
Also, wenn man sich jetzt mal
vorstellt, ne?
Das hier wäre jetzt ein Passwortbuch.
So, also quasi
pro Zeile
so eine Random-Sache, ne?
So.
Wie konnte man nochmal eine
Zeilennummer...
Warte mal. Bash
Put Line Number
in Front. Gab's da auch sowas?
Ja.
NL.
NL?
Was? So?
Ne.
Kann man das
am Wimp halten oder so?
Ey, ich will...
Ah, so, verstehe.
Verstehe.
Okay, ich bin zu luft dafür, Zeilnummern vor den Kram zu schreiben.
Keine Ahnung, wie das funktioniert.
Keine Ahnung wie das funktioniert.
Okay, dann machen wir das jetzt anders.
pwgen umleiten
nach blub.txt
vim blub txt
set...
...
Moment, der Unterschied zwischen
umgeleitet in ne Datei und so ist anders?
Ach so!
Aber ist das doch richtig, die ich gemacht habe?
Ähm.
Wie viele?
Number?
Aha.
Ah, guck mal, es funktioniert doch.
So, also gehen wir jetzt mal von außen.
Gehen wir jetzt mal von außen.
So, ich habe jetzt ein Passwortbuch.
Und ich merke mir jetzt nur die Zeile.
dann ist es doch total easy.
Da muss man einfach nur jede Zeile einmal durchprobieren.
Das geht doch viel schneller. Da muss man doch hier nicht
Brut forcen am Passwort. Da ist man doch innerhalb
von ein paar Sekunden durch.
Ihr Passwortgenerator
as a Service hier
fühlt euch
frei, die Passwörter zu verwenden.
Ich
Ich generate euch nochmal ein paar.
Hier, habt ihr noch ein paar.
Oh, nice.
Ja.
Oh, ich muss gleich auf.
naja
also
eigentlich
wäre es nicht verkehrt
die Passwörter nochmal zu ändern
weil
wenn du aus der Cloud
raus willst, weil du der ganzen Sache
nicht mehr so richtig traust
und lässt einfach da alles so wie es ist
beziehungsweise
du dir nicht sicher sein kannst wer vielleicht noch jemals zugriff darauf hatte oder noch haben
wird oder ob alles richtig gelöscht wird müsstest du eigentlich danach deine passwörter noch mal
ändern ich wäre wahrscheinlich zu faul und würde die passwörter wirklich nur bei den essentiellen
sachen ändern ob ich jetzt irgendwie die die fünfte fake mail adresse sichern würde noch
mal weiß ich nicht ich würde meine main e mail adresse noch mal ändern main google account und
und sowas. Das würde ich wahrscheinlich nochmal machen.
Sirius Max, danke
für den Sub.
Chat.
Schon, dass so viele am Start waren.
Auch zu einer etwas ungewöhnlichen Zeit für mich.
Dienstag, 17 Uhr bis 19.30 Uhr.
Wenn ihr dabei sein wollt, wenn wir Trunas ausprobieren,
dann wäre es jetzt sehr sinnvoll, mir einfach einen Follow dazulassen.
Dann seht ihr das nächste Mal nämlich direkt mit am Start.
Und wir können uns das zusammen angucken.
Erstes Mal Trunas ausprobieren.
Weil der Chat hat ein paar Mal schon gesagt, das ist mittlerweile richtig gut.
Welche Zeiten sind gewöhnlich? Das ist das Problem. Also ich habe eine feste Streamingzeit und das ist sonntags zum Aufstehen so 3-4 Stunden.
Ansonsten unter der Woche meistens so ab 16.30, 17 Uhr, aber auch unregelmäßig. Also ich kann dir nicht sagen, ich bin jetzt nächsten Donnerstag da.
Stimmt, du hast recht
Wir könnten das auf dem U-Cream machen
Aber zu besseren Vergleichen
Sollten wir es wahrscheinlich
Schon auf dem Minis-Forum machen
Aber auch das U-Cream
Wäre vielleicht anders verkehrt
Aber Sonntag machen wir kein Bastelkram.
Sonntag gucken wir uns an was, keine Ahnung, auf GitHub die Woche passiert ist oder sowas.
Und irgendwelche neuen Technik-Bastelvideos auf YouTube oder solche Geschichten.
Also sonntagsmorgens bin ich noch nicht, ist mein Gehirn noch nicht in der Lage großartig
zu basteln.
rfprogrammer, wie sieht es eigentlich mit Katzis aus bei dir?
Bist du immer noch in...
Ich habe vergessen, wie die Stadt hieß.
Irgendwas mit I?
Kann das sein?
Izmir, genau.
Gibt viele Katzis.
Was machst du da eigentlich?
Bist du da beruflich unterwegs?
Was ist der Plan?
Stimmt VPNs einrichten.
Heute wurde Cloud-Code-Source-Code geleakt.
Wirklich?
Nicht?
Ach.
Was ist das?
Guck mal da.
Cloud-Code-Source-Code ist beleakt via Map-File in der NPM-Registry.
Was?
Ja, Moment.
Ein Map-File ist ja
diese Geschichte,
dass du Zuordnung hast
von kompiliertem Code
zum Debug-Zwecken zu den
jeweiligen Source-Code-Zeilen.
Steht da wirklich der
komplette
der komplette
Source-Code dann drin?
aber da irgendwas beise axios das kann es ja mittlerweile nichts mehr installieren er
klopper kompletter der quellcode von anthropics tropics tool cloud code wurde versehentlich über
eine source map in der wm es ist warum ist es bei allem immer npm leute immer npm ich meine
das ist jetzt was anderes wie bei supply aber es ist auch npm immer npm alter ich
lade mir bestimmt nicht hier im stream irgendwelche sachen davon runter der
quellkopf von anzügen okay
der sicherheitsexperte schaufann so macht über twitter auf den fund
aufmerksam 19.900 dateien mit über 512.000
ja genau
Tja, verkackt würde ich sagen, hä?
Hart verkackt haben sie.
Das ist bestimmt schon takedown, oder?
Was?
Was ist denn das jetzt schon wieder?
Das den Code Analysezwecken
Spiegel ausdrücklich als Forschungslehrmaterial
eingeordnet. Okay.
Tja.
Wir haben es rewriten lassen von
Claude Code selber, dass es nicht mehr den
dem eigentlichen Source-Code entspricht.
Das ist natürlich Pfeifert.
Das ist Pfeifert.
Das ist ja geil.
Da trifft sie mal selbst.
Ansonsten klauen sie sich ja von überall
ihre Trainingsdaten zusammen.
Und jetzt trifft sie es mal selbst.
gibt es diesbezüglich dann irgendwelche folgen müssen wir abwarten ich glaube nicht dass den
leuten die das auf github packen irgendwas passiert wie konnte das passieren ich denke
mal die haben irgendeine bild pipeline für ihre npm packages hat irgend einer was gepusht dann
liefen die ganzen jobs durch und an irgendeiner stelle kommt dann halt der
workflow der step removing die bug files oder irgendwie sowas und der ist wohl
aus irgendwelchen gründen fehlgeschlagen
und da sind die drin geblieben
Axios Supply Chain Attack.
Na toll.
Axios ist saumäßig beliebt.
Dürfen wir nicht vergessen.
Es hat Millionen Downloads.
Guck mal, Weekly Downloads.
101.
Was auch immer.
101 Millionen.
Millionen Downloads pro Woche.
Aber nicht zwangsläufig die
Natürlich nicht zwangsläufig die
Infizierte Version
Ja
Aber das wird schon oft runtergeladen
Heftig
Und steht vielleicht
Es steht noch nicht mal News hier dran
Irgendwie, was ist mit denen los
Ich hätte gesagt, da steht fett ne News
Achtung, wenn ihr Versionen so und so benutzt
Das ist ein HTTP-Client.
Für alle, die keinen Bock auf Fetch haben,
können Axios verwenden.
Fetch ist ja mittlerweile auch in Node.js
und so standardmäßig drin, soweit ich weiß.
Execute Post-Install-Scripts
that acts as a cross-platform remote access Trojaner.
Super.
Na toll.
Genau das, was man gebraucht hat.
Deswegen entwickle ich nur noch in Dev-Containern, Leute.
Mit Dev-Container passiert es einem dann zwar auch, dass man sich das einfängt,
aber die sind erstmal in der Sandbox drin.
Wenn man natürlich sein Docker-Socket weiterleitet in den Dev-Container,
dass man da drin Docker ausführen kann, dann kriegst du Easy-Root-Rechte.
Aber das macht man ja auch nicht.
Interessant.
Power off.
So, Chat.
Ich muss jetzt leider off.
Wir sehen uns dann...
Ah, wir sehen uns jetzt ja ganz oft.
Nächsten Tag fällt mir da auf.
Es ist jetzt ja nur noch Mittwoch, Donnerstag arbeiten.
Dann ist Freitag, Samstag, Sonntag, Montag.
Ist ja Ostern.
Vielleicht schaffe ich es ja.
dadurch dass ich mich jetzt eine weile ausgeruht haben mich dann wieder ausruhen kann
vielleicht sogar mittwoch donnerstag kurz mal abends zu streamen
und dann über ostern das war mal ein paar tage am stück stream so haben
Wobei ich das wie gesagt nicht versprechen kann je nachdem wie kaputt ich morgen bin wenn ich von der arbeit kommen müssen wir mal gucken
Aber wir können auf jeden fall an entweder mittwoch oder donnerstag ist donnerstag wieder ein kein stream stream machen
Wo wir ein bisschen schwätzen.
Wo wir ein bisschen schwätzen und uns aktuelles Teuch angucken.
Oder ihr mich irgendwas fragen könnt.
Oder Stellen anzeigen, uns angucken können, was euch gerade so auf dem Herzen liegt.
Weil da muss ich mir keine Gedanken im Vorfeld zu machen.
Das kann ich immer machen.
Okay.
So, dann machen wir das hier mal dicht.
Hau auf.
AliExpress-Stream.
Das ist in der Tat eine gute Idee.
Ein Problem ist, dass ich aktuell
nichts im Kopf habe, was ich bei AliExpress
kaufen will.
Ich hätte mal richtig Bock
wieder auf China-Chinesen-Einkauf-Stream.
Aber es gibt
gerade nichts,
was ich haben will.
10GB-Netzwerkkarten.
Ja.
Die löte ich dann aufs Mainboard drauf.
Ja, ich hab schon geschuckt.
Und das ist preis-leistungsmäßig nicht übel.
Problem bei den geschuckten Festplatten ist halt immer, dass du keine Garantie hast.
Und wenn du dir viele Festplatten kaufst und nur eine geht davon kaputt,
und du hast keine Garantie drauf, der hat sich schon wieder nicht mehr gelohnt.
Also das ist so ein zweischneidiges Schwert, das Festplatten-Geschucke.
Es ist deutlich billiger, aber du hast halt keine Garantie.
Also schwer zu sagen, ob das sich lohnt oder nicht.
Also wenn man mal davon ausgeht, die Festplatte geht und geht nicht kaputt,
dann ist Schuppen deutlich günstiger.
Also 499 Euro zu 720 Euro, ja.
Es ist aber eigentlich immer noch Wahnsinn.
Selbst 499 ist Wahnsinn für eine 24T-Platte.
So Leute, dann bin ich wirklich auf.
Bis denn, wir sehen uns die Tage, macht's gut.
C.U.
Vielen Dank.